e
e e
morning
everybody good morning um is there
anybody of our members out in the hall
requesting our members please take their
seats
morning representative H Haskins good
morning
okay I believe today representative
Howard and representative siketus will
be out due to illness just so everybody
is
aware I'm going to uh ask representative
Penza to lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Al to the FL of the United States of
America and to the rep for it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you and again good morning
this is environment agriculture
committee I am going to start off by
passing around
around a
copies
of
um the air the section of the uh hb2 the
trailer
Bill uh where uh the governor has
inserted um information or proposed
legislation for the establishment of a
solid waste site evaluation committee
and I'd like the committee to take some
time to review this so that we can
discuss it I know I did send it out
electronically um and you may have
reviewed it already but I did want to
make sure that everybody got a hard copy
so I'm going to pass that around each
way there you
go um and it's going to be important for
us to discuss this as a committee
because I know that Finance where the
hb2 trailer bill is right now will be
looking for our input as to our
recommendations uh regarding uh this
language that's in
there and I also know that uh some of
and so this goes from page
14 to page 24 I
believe yes um so that that particular
section I'd like us to uh pay particular
attention to I know that some of this
what what they're proposing may already
be in some some shape or way shape or
form uh in bills that we are have
already uh considered or are considering
or have passed or may may be passing
today uh and we can uh
certainly um you know at some point
there may be a committee conference to
sort of
you know smooth everything out make sure
everything jives but um so I just wanted
to bring that to your attention
also um we are going to be deviating
from our normal normal schedule and
meeting this week tomorrow on a
Wednesday we normally meet on Tuesdays
uh we're going to be doubling up on this
week and also the week after next week
when we come back from school vacation
week because we won't be having
committee meetings
next week um so
for I'm planning on uh meeting March 4th
and 5th
um March 11th possibly March 12th I
don't know yet I I I've left that open
um certainly we still have a bunch of
bills ahead of us um we're we're we're
working on right now the food bills and
then we're going to start getting into
animal welfare bills so just so you have
an idea that we may be meeting um couple
of Wednesdays coming
up
okay um we have a work session ahead of
us now and I wanted to catch up with
everybody about comments
regarding uh several of these bills that
are listed on our executive session
sheet um
uh let's see we have the work session
sheet here what did I do with it yeah oh
here it is I'm
sorry so on our uh full committee work
session
sheet the first item that I wanted to
discuss with you all was
hb150 and I believe representative ktoa
has an amendment to that that she'd like
to explain to
us thank thank you madam chair um during
the presentation it came to our
attention that we didn't use the word
sanitize and that was extremely
important in making sure uh that anytime
we're processing food we're sanitizing
equipment so uh the change was instead
of saying uh washed and rinsed is uh was
changed to to be cleaned and sanitized
in the processing area it's just a a
real simple change uh and everybody I
put this in front on everyone's desk so
they could uh take a look at that
otherwi that was the only change that
was
made okay represent vix um I think this
makes a lot of sense I think it's a a
lot is both more consistent with food
safety practice and um I think that uh
yes so I think that it makes more sense
in terms of how people would actually do
things okay yeah I uh I absolutely think
this is an improvement and I have no
problem with this amendment and I will
be looking forward to supporting it when
we go into exec session uh to get this
uh bill passed
hb150 any other questions or comments
regarding
hb150 okay thank you um moving along we
have HB 307 relative to food production
area for Homestead
food um I know that we when after we
heard the
bill uh we had some thoughts that we
might execute right away but I know that
representative King had some reservation
wanted to uh look at some of the
statutes that it was referring to um but
I think um there was also some thought
about making some amendment to it
represent Bixby do you yes so um uh so
um yeah yeah
so
um Addie whose last name I'm blanking on
right now but it's probably on the sheet
here uh leader zavos yes um uh um sent a
sent uh a I'm not sure if she sent it to
the full committee or just to me but a
uh a proposed um some proposed amendment
language and uh I think that a lot of it
makes sense so um I think that uh this
is one that we should take a little time
to um look over and um and do an
amendment for uh our next uh session uh
as opposed to um executing it today so
uh and
the
um what the what her language
essentially does is it uh lays out some
clearer uh um requirements for what that
second what a secondary food production
area would need to be able to uh what
would what would qualify an area for
that and uh so um accessibility to
handwashing which is really key for any
sort of food production um and equipment
and food storage so um making sure the
area has to uh allow for
uh sanitary um uh storage of food
equipment and utensils uh the area needs
to have food um have Food Services food
contact surfaces that are
sanitizable uh
and uh which is really key for
maintaining proper sanitation in uh in a
food production area uh and uh it also
has to be the whole area needs to be
uh maintain maintainable in a clean and
S sanitary uh condition free from PES
and environmental contaminants and it
needs to allow for pet
exclusion uh and I think that's um
that's also an important uh aspect of it
and I think it might that might imp fact
make the area better than the average
home kitchen because uh sometimes pet
exclusion is a little challenging for
home kitchen
uh but uh although that is in fact
required under current uh rules for you
when you are working in your home
kitchen you need to exclude pets um so I
think all of those elements of of the uh
of what she's suggesting makes sense uh
I'm she's also suggested uh changing the
word poten potentially hazardous food
for time temperature control safe
control for safety food for food safety
uh and that
um the uh I'm cons a little bit
concerned about that because there are
some potentially ha hazardous foods
where the issue is not the time temp
temperature control uh and I think
partic particularly of uh canned items
uh low acid canned items are not uh an
time uh time temperature control is not
the issue with low acid items uh it is
in fact you know that it's just that if
you don't uh use a pressure caner with
those and have your pressure caner
properly properly calibrated uh it can
allow for uh the introduction of
botulism which is an incredibly
poisonous back um contaminant so um I
think that the we probably want to stick
with the potentially hazardous food
since that is reasonably well defined
already in
um in uh in our food safety
laws okay thank you um and I I
absolutely appreciate um these comments
that were submitted to the committee wi
with regard to proposed revisions for
hp37 I think they really are
comprehensive and take into account a
lot of the open issues that were that
were voiced when we had the hearing uh
well done thank you so much for that
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair uh representative Bixby will you
be bringing forth the amendment yes I'll
uh get it drafted for our next for our
um the executive session that happens
after school break so I think that's the
March 4th March 4th yes so um this
afternoon because it's on our exec list
uh I am going to um recess it to March
3rd um March
4th thank you
okay um let's see the next one on our
list to talk about is HB
479 and I know when we heard HB
479 um we we had wanted to execute right
away and we didn't have we wanted to itl
the bill and uh representative Penza was
going to draft a letter to the solid
waste working group
um on that so um but we never got to it
that afternoon so here it is on our work
schedule this morning and uh hopefully
we can uh exec the bill uh later this
morning um representative Penza did you
have any comment on that bill or does
anybody have any comment on that
bill representative
Penza no I don't have any comment I just
haven't I haven't drafted that letter
yet but I will yeah no worries I can do
it today okay um so of Bixby yeah so um
just an offer that uh I'd be happy to to
help with any drafting if you uh if
you're looking for help we're looking
for a second pair of eyes okay you guys
will work on it thank you I appreciate
that yep but um so we the plan is then
to um itl that study committee bill
um in our exec session or later this
morning okay moving to
hb77 requiring the Department of
Environmental Services to establish a
site specific setback distance for
proposed new
landfills and I believe representative
Penza you were working on an amendment
to that I don't believe that amendment
is ready for today no no no it's not
it's um it's very close though so I
could probably I don't I don't have a
draft from OS but I could give you like
my draft if we wanted to do that I could
send it up to have printed um I have
that on the list of exec bills on March
4th okay so and we will have a a chance
uh to further discuss that um tomorrow
um or if you want to further discuss
that today um we could definitely
further discuss it tomorrow um I'll have
I'll have a draft of what um but not
from OS but a draft of the changes that
we've discussed or like in open in the
hearing and stuff for everyone so they
can super representative Bixby yeah so I
was wondering if you had um uh worked on
including language for that um in terms
of uh the area where leate would be
handled I have not touched anything with
Le okay so um so that that um uh I I
don't think that we need to so one of
the an issue came up or uh in our
discussion of the leech a bill last week
in terms of you know whether uh whether
the area at a um at a landfill where
lee8 is stored and
transferred uh is required to be
under uh to to have a uh double whining
underneath it to catch any potential
spills and
uh the answer from that we got from
uh uh Mike whims at did say that he did
say that that is part of the you know
assessing the uh the area where leate is
handled and stored is part of the review
process but he but he did not say that
it is that there is a double lining
required underneath that and um that
might be something that we want to add
to the set to to 707 uh in order to make
sure that we do in fact have you know
every potential spillage um area covered
by the bill yeah I think it's a
fantastic idea I just
um can that be implemented in in such a
way that because this is basically
updating rules you know the 800 rules so
can that be implemented in my bill in
such a way that um it could be just you
know four or five lines and not like
that's what I'm saying to get into a
real big long explanation that's what I
think that's the only piece that I was
concerned
with representative germana thank you
madam chair uh yeah I'm I'm hap very
happy to work with repr representative
pateno we had a preliminary conversation
because we had decided that 77 was
probably more appropriate because it's
about operations as opposed to 2115
which is about about the plan uh and I
do think it's something we could
probably do in three lines so I'm very
happy to work with representative prends
on that language yep that sounds like a
really good plan
yep
okay all right uh let me just make my
note
[Music]
here okay cool
all right uh now moving on to any other
questions or comments about that one 707
no okay thank you for that um moving on
to um
hr10 which is uh recognizing the
fundamental right to have clean air
clean water and a healthy environment as
a house resolution um I did present an
an amendment to the committee uh last
week and I hope that you reviewed it and
and um I plan to move that um when we do
exec session this morning representative
Bixby yeah I think that I'm um I I still
prefer the language that uses rights but
uh I'm but in terms of you know the
final disposition of the bill coming out
of committee I'm uh I think that uh
whether or not it's amended I think it
makes sense just um to pass to pass it
so um I think that uh we'll we'll see
that we we'll deal with that when it
comes to the executive session okay
thank you appreciate that all right any
other questions or comments regarding
that okay HB
2115 requiring a landfill permit
applicant to submit a report listing
potential harms and benefits of the
project that is an early Bill we really
should um have that done today so um I
believe representative gero was working
on that and as I see we have an
amendment
would you like to speak to your
amendment I would thank you very much
Madam chair so this uh is uh a
combination of discussions that uh
ongoing discussions that I have had with
director whim sad and also from work
session and our Solid Waste subcommittee
uh and so uh one note that I would make
is that the amendment that you're
looking at here replaces section one in
the bill as introduced
sections two through
five remain as they are in the
introduced version this is just how OS
prints out the amendment they don't
replace the whole bill um but this
section was the one where we spelled out
some of the details around the defining
n public benefit and a process for
determining for example how an
independent third party would be
contracted and so uh as you can see
originally a b and c
are already in
statute the original Bill had just one
more provision that was D but working
with director whims we have fleshed out
in section d uh for example how the
third party would be contracted in this
case U an applicant would submit a list
of
third-party uh reviewers to Dees Dees
would review that list would work with
the applic and the host Community to try
to identify a mutually acceptable third
party if Dees doesn't feel that they
have been given adequate if they feel
that the list the applicant gave them is
really not adequate they can ask for
more uh and if uh a mutually um agreed
upon party is not found within 60 days
the commissioner shall choose based upon
uh the list that they
have then section e this is something I
I talked to the committee about already
uh I think this is a really good
addition it uh expands actually the list
of potential benefits that can be
considered to include uh economic
potential economic benefits and
improvements to infrastructure and the
purpose here uh and again this came from
my conversations with the director uh is
to make sure that this is genuinely
about finding what that balance is so if
we're looking for potential harms to
tourism to uh you know the local economy
to property values Etc we're also
looking at potential benefits so it's
creating hopefully a much more balanced
uh list of things on both sides that we
are are looking at uh and I think that's
something actually that
industry will appreciate because
according to the director they have for
years argued that benefits should go
beyond simply capacity need so as I said
I think this provides a more balanced uh
approach to um benefits and and
potential harms you know one of the
concerns that's been raised about some
of our bills is the idea that it's about
saying that nobody can ever site a
landfill in the state again and that's
not not the case and I think that this
paragraph is a good example of trying to
find a place where we are genuinely
trying to conclude what the ultimate net
benefit uh would be to the community and
then sections f and g again clarify more
regarding the thirdparty assess
assessment
um section
F gives Dees the ability to coordinate
with the Department of Transportation
the Department of Business and economic
Affairs and the Department of Natural
and cultural resources to help provide
expertise in the evaluation of the third
party report and that's an initial kind
of screening phase uh that is explained
in uh section g so uh one of the
differences uh actually quite a bit of
the language from this bill I think is
is reflected in the governor's proposal
on on
hb2 the difference here uh and this
again came out of discussions with the
director is that in this bill it is done
in the beginning there's an initial
screening phase for public benefit the
idea of the site evaluation committee
would actually come toward the end of
that process so that's a difference
between this bill and that bill um but
in this B as section g points out it
will be a preliminary stage and only if
there is a determination of net public
benefit would an application then go on
to uh further
review okay thank you representative
King thank you madam chair and uh thank
you representative germana for all the
work you put into this uh quick question
about
um uh subsection D um you're talking
about the um the contractors who are
going to help the third parties there um
what kind of contractors are you
thinking of I'm you know originally I
was thinking of sort of like NOS or some
sort of like um you know sort of public
community service kind of organization
but when you mean contractors what what
is meant by that can you just explain
who these who these contractors will be
what they'll do yes thank you very much
and that's something that the the
director said that they would have to
kind of familiarize themselves with the
world he said offand you know there
weren't specific say firms that he had
in mind but they would be uh you know
environmental impact statements both at
the federal and state level are very
very common 16 states have systems that
require environmental impacts as does
the federal government and so there are
uh organizations they are Environ
sometimes environmental engineering
firms for example who regularly engage
in the work of um evaluations for
environmental impact statements so uh
I'm afraid I can't give you you know the
names of specific firms but uh there are
uh environmental engineering firms that
do this regularly at the state and
federal level okay followup followup
yeah okay so it's not necessarily local
organizations in that Community it could
be larger organizations that are outside
that Community yes that is correct and I
and I think that the point of having a
list submitted by the applicant and and
then Dees is going to review it and you
know the purpose is to find a variety
right so you know there may be one
locally there may be one regionally but
it is to provide several different
options for everyone involved to
consider represent Bixby yeah so um so
Adam fle who has been uh many of us are
on the committee are familiar with him
he's done a lot of uh uh given us a lot
of help in terms of figuring out what
makes sense in terms of setback
requirements and a number of other
things uh he worked in uh in benefit and
uh cost benefit analysis for the federal
government for decades uh and has also
taught that at the uh at the University
level and uh he uh he commented that
this is because the federal government
uses and a number of states use this
sort of service a lot there are many
firms out there that uh whose business
is is working on
this okay good representative
ktoa uh yes thank you thank you madam
chair
um just a quick question on
the what would disqualify or make the
department decide that one of the
contractors on the list is not
acceptable and what is the criteria for
that thank you for that question uh and
I would have to follow up with the
director he's the one who suggested that
um that be put in there uh but he didn't
tell me what would constitute a
disqualification so I can I can make an
inquiry about that mam sure yeah because
if someone's giving a list then they
need to
know um kind of what the criteria is
that the Department's looking for in a
contractor um you know and make sure
that you know someone's not wasting
their
time so thank
you represent Penza I'm sorry
representative ger you had a reply thank
you yes and I think that's an excellent
point I can follow up with the director
I will say as as uh Amy maneli said when
she testified before the committee that
this process is always a negotiation
right so that that kind of communication
between the applicant and the department
would would be regular to try to Define
what those parameters are but I will
definitely try to to get more
clarification from the
Department representative Penza and then
H Haskins yeah I agree with
representative gerana great question
though representative ktoa um I think
it's just there's so many people from
the research that U we've done in this
whole um net public benefit it it's been
going on for a very very long time um
there's there's agencies that are
actually already most of the contractors
or the let's say um the industry is
already using this on their own so
before they're even even if a state's
not requiring it they have to know that
because they still have to put forward
their project so environmental Engineers
um hydrogeologists that are that are
looking at impact um and then they also
get the other side of it which is like
truly just the pure business side of it
as well so um this is something that I
guess is is very familiar I don't have a
problem in a sense with um with Dees
determining if they
are um you know kind of like a qualified
contractor I think to me it would be
someone that is doing that work so you
know um if they're not doing that work
and they're maybe on what I just said
one side versus the other they need to
have somebody that's really balanced and
I think that's the reason why that's in
there I'm okay with that but maybe for
it to have some sort of qualifier is
okay too so um but I don't think we can
be very specific in this legislation it
has to be a little bit open so um but um
I'm really happy with the amendment
thank you for all your work yeah
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair I too am um grateful for the work
that's gone into this it's very
comprehensive I think it's going to help
us a lot I'm concerned about the pre
when the preliminary review is done is
the legislature and perhaps the solid
waste subcommittee is somebody going to
be brought up to date on where things
stand and notified if there's a problem
with the preliminary review
representative germana uh I not more so
than we already have right so if
somebody puts in an application and for
whatever reason it fails so for example
you know cassella has already put in a
number of of permit applications and
there have been issues with those uh and
have been returned to Cella and we don't
get informed every time that happen
happen so um no there would not be more
of a formal notification process than we
already have when permit applications
are returned to applicants
representative H Haskins followup thank
you so if you're content with that that
we would um in the the work that the
subcommittee has done and perhaps would
continue to do that we wouldn't know
exactly how the permitting process is
going or how that preliminary review
part of the process is
going I I I am comfortable with it the
way it is I don't think we need to build
in a formal notification process I mean
we can those of us who are interested
and there a lot of us can always make
inquiries and that information will be
made available so I'm comfortable with
the way it is okay representative Bixby
yeah uh I have most I mainly have
another another sort of observation
question but I just wanted to say that
um our departments do a vast number of
permit applications we do not want to be
informed of the proc of of every step of
the process of every permit application
going on um it would make the email from
the most contentious bill look
trivial okay so um but my uh my
observation SL question is so in section
e where you're talking about potential
benefits
um you all you end on uh page two line
five uh and other factors identify as
identified by the contractor uh which I
think uh is a we can't anticipate all of
the potential benefits that someone
might come up with so I think that makes
sense but I just want to clarify that we
do still have at a later section in the
bill that any potential benefit or harm
has to be Rel related to the specific
site and it so it can't that that other
Factor can't be something in another
part of the state right right yes thank
you very much that's an excellent point
one of the other sections in the bill
which is not included in this amendment
says that it's it is a onetoone right
you can make a claim for benefits at one
location not bundling multiple locations
yes correct I I was under that
understanding as
well representative
guber thank thank you madam chair um I'm
very supportive of how this has evolved
and I think we've addressed the uh the
comments we've had through many uh
feedback on the public hearings uh just
just want to make a note that as a
professional engineer um sending out
statements of qualifications there's a
protocol experience background
references uh it's a very common
practice that I reviewed from
Consultants I think it could be done
well by what's laid out here for what
the statement qualification should cover
okay all right any other represent
Penza um I just I know that we're going
to talk about this at another time I
just um just because it's in reference
to this I think that um where did you
just pass that out um here we
go okay so in the in HB I mean um
sb2 um the trailer Bill correct y I just
want everybody to make notice CU I think
it's really
important
um at the bottom of page
[Music]
um uh
applications not contain yes
so until it has in quotes until all
other state agency approvals have been
attained I just think
um it's really important I think our
bill is very important because this is
this is the preliminary like you know
where we've been talking about like in a
sense if there was a you know phase one
and phase two process um having having a
company um go through you know five
years worth of work and then have
possibly a panel of five people say hey
sorry your project tuck didn't work that
that just doesn't you know that just
doesn't fly so I hope um I'm very
appreciative of all the work that the
governor is doing and getting involved
in in the solid waste discussions and I
think it's important but I also think
it's important that um the legislature
is clear like we've been kind of living
and breathing this for a long time and
in this process here to have that be at
the end would would provide such a
discern to um you know to the applicants
and all of that so and we will
know in the beginning that's the whole
point right if there if someone's
putting a proposal together of like the
worst you know it's the worst possible
location it's it you know there's no
clay it's in it's in poor sand all of
that kind of stuff that we could rule
that out in the beginning um why would
EV you know why would we have this be
right at the end of you know it could be
as much as a fiveyear process with a
permit so I just wanted to put that
there because I have spent a little bit
of time on this and um but when we get
into the nitty-gritty of that you know
I'll bring up those types of things and
I hope you know that I don't know if we
could have that kind of open
conversation with the governor I think
that would be wonderful um we could do
that as a committee to say hey thank you
so much um here are some things where
we're doing on the legislative side of
things we we hope you sign these bills
and it it might not be necessary to have
some of of these things in hb2 so just
my two cents yep um that's why I I do I
want I want to encourage everybody to
start marking this up and making notes
and saying well you know this is already
covered in something that we've passed
um it may be on its way to the Senate
who knows what the senate or the other
people across the wall whatever you want
to call them um yeah uh so whatever
whatever they decide to do with it but
at the end of the day we do want all
this legisl that we've been working on
both on our side and the other side to
jive with what is policy in the budget
Bill if it's policy in the budget bill
is conflicting we have to make a
decision where we're going with this and
I think that that may happen in a
committee conference it may happen on
the Senate side we on the other side
whatever um so but let's start marking
this up and and that
way mostly because the FI house finance
is looking for direction from us as to
whether or not what this policy is
that's going into um hp2 makes any sense
at all representative
Penza thank you madam chair
um the other piece of this is we have we
have some committees councils already
set up right so are we going to now send
set up another council is this going to
take away from one versus the other and
if it did one if it was fully you know
occupied actually is is um is a little
bit more representative for the public
and and for the environment as well as
the industry it's more balanced than
what this would be so there's there's
some conflicts in there which um you
know we setting up another another
entity just specifically when we already
have that like it yeah so there's some
confusion in there um just based upon
some of this you know the solid waste
Council and stuff like that so it's my
intention uh for for us to set aside
some time to maybe do a work session on
this policy that's in the budget Bill uh
a the week after we come back from uh
next week uh break because that'll give
us some time to look it over review it
and with the mindset of uh you know the
the um the solid waste bills that we're
intending on passing later this morning
um which we've all been working on and
this is kind of what we've decided as
policy we want to have and uh if again
if that doesn't mesh with something
that's in this budget bill then we have
to bring that out and and see if we can
make a tweak to what's in the budget
bill or maybe we just say yeah no that's
not really a great idea maybe uh Finance
needs to strike that whole section out
uh you know that's that's a discussion
we have to have representative Bixby
yeah uh I just like to say I that I
agree with representative patten's
concerns uh and I have some additional
ones on top of that uh I I see the I I
think there are number of valuable
protective elements that the governor is
s
suggesting uh I'm really concerned with
having them all sort of evaluated at the
very end yeah and uh and I think that
in terms of the legislation we're
working on uh what we're working on is
essentially a policy that is a house
position and uh so we don't need to pay
attention to the go what the governor is
saying in her uh in in her proposal for
hb2 in order to evaluate the uh the
merits of the policy and the bills that
we're looking at we need to pass we need
to
um work on those I and given that they
mostly seem pretty good with a little
bit of tweaking pass them with
amendments uh but uh that's that's what
we need to do and then we can have
negotiations based on what we worked on
there of there are things that the
governor has noticed that need to be
addressed that are not in um in one of
our bills that's something that would be
perhaps uh something to be negotiated
for
hb2 agreed anyone
else okay um I just want to say I want
to uh again U uh Echo that um the work
that representative King and
representative gerana and representative
Penza all of us have put into this um HB
215 and the amendment um I want to
congratulate you guys on on doing a
really good job and listening
to people who have testified what their
concerns and what their preferences are
as well as working with department and
department heads uh on on what is
workable and what makes sense um and I
think we've come out with um a really
good policy so thank you
all um moving on to HB 566 requiring
permit applications for new landfills to
contain a detailed plan for leech 8
management and I have before me as well
um an amendment to that
bill oh we have yet a new one an amended
Amendment an amended Amendment okay so
let me put this
aside amended Amendment okay cool
passing this along to everybody and I
believe representative gerana wants to
uh talk to us about this amendment thank
you very much Madam chair and and and
the the most recent amended version
which is being passed out now there were
a couple of additions that
Representatives uh Scully and Gruber
recommended in our solid waste
subcommittee that have been incorporated
into this amendment so specifically uh
at line
um uh let's see here yes uh line 10 if
you go up actually to the beginning of
the sentence at line 8 the lee8
management plan shall include at minimum
a description of how leech 8 will be
collected and stored on site and then
the following Clause was added um by
recommendation in the solid way
subcommittee if and how it will be
treated on site so for example right now
TurnKey treats on site uh so we wanted
to include if someone is treating on
site that this plan would would include
their description of that process and
then down at line 13 and I think this
was uh very good recommendation I
believe it was representative Scully uh
that the plan include details of all
contractual agreements between the
applicant and at least two facilities
that will be engaged in the transport
and the processing of lee8 so that we
know that their plan includes backup
contingencies if their primary
contracted uh facility is unable to to
meet their needs I spoke with director
whims about that he said that you know
they would actually they they like
having at least two in the statute in
rule they may say at least three they
want that flexibility to require more
but he said at least two would be a good
addition to statute so I appreciate I
think it was representative Scully who
who um who proposed that so we had that
implemented so uh what this bill does is
lines five through about 14 talk about
the plan
that you would submit with your uh
application for lee8 management and then
the remainder starting on 14 through 21
speak specifically to what has to be
included in contractual agreements and
the director said that he he sees this
as uh strengthening their rules and the
application of their rules he said that
currently uh these facilities have to
operators have to have
you know they tell Dees we have these
contracts but uh what this statute will
do is actually require more details from
those contracts be reported to Dees and
the director said that that would be
very helpful for their managing
compliance
okay very good any questions or
comments thank you for reviewing this
with us and thank you for putting it
together and again I appreciate the work
you and others have done
in bringing this amendment to us for
this bill and making the bill a better
Bill especially as a co-sponsor I'm real
happy about
that okay thank you um and then we are
up to HB
153 requiring that two or more law
enforcement officers in each County
receive training regarding animal
cruelty I believe representative ktoa uh
had a subcommittee meeting to discuss
this and oh I see an
amendment thank you madam every on this
again okay there it's going around here
we go okay so we have an amendment uh
thank you madam chair
um due to some issues only uh two
committee members were able to be here
um however all stakeholders were here so
we had a representation from police
standards and training the state police
um the Chiefs
of police uh Farm Bureau Humane Society
and someone from the governor's
Commission on the Humane treatment of
animals um all were part of this
subcommittee on Friday um it was
discussed at Great length um
that this bill we've been working on a
similar bill was tried to be passed last
session but we really need to make sure
we get it right and we felt that forming
a study committee would would be in the
best interest
uh it would be the most productive way
to get this done I'm not sure how to
handle this where we didn't actually
vote in our subcommittee um but we did
like I said with all the stakeholders
and um talked
about
the uh turning it into a study committee
so my recommendation is this and if
anyone has any suggestions or questions
on the amendment um basically as uh
representative Bixby knows I put down
three representatives and only one
Senator um only from past
experiences um and basically what the um
will be established a study committee
adding a Statewide resource to assist
with the investigation training
prosecution and prompt response of
animal
cruelty it was suggested at our
subcommittee meeting that it might be a
volunteer group of law enforcement um
officers that would be willing to be
resources for this um how that we would
do that we're not sure we do know that
um if law enforcement goes out uh there
would need to be some type of a
reimbursement uh and is that from the
municipality or however that does Works
um we need to look at existing training
that is provided by the New Hampshire
police standards and training Council
and other courses that may be available
either in state or out of state um
because there is already
um Education and Training throughout the
us on this right now at the police
standards anyone going through the
academy gets a 2-hour crash course in
our animal cruelty laws um but there are
resources online to help assist them in
this but not everyone accesses that and
how do we get people to you know the old
adage was used you can bring a horse to
water but you can't make it drink um the
other thing was is to identify the best
way to train law enforcement and other
stakeholders including prosecutors
because uh apparently a lot of these
cases end up at the county level and the
County Prosecutors really aren't aware
of these laws also uh so there might be
uh we may need to have some training
there um
obviously we want to identify the best
way to form a group to be a resource for
others in New Hampshire uh we recognize
that having a group to assist with
promptness of calls will be in the best
interest in of animals in distress so
you know how do we make sure that that
happens um we want to work with all the
agencies involved in the mission and
identify any other issues that may need
to be fil fulfill to fulfill the intent
of this committee um and that's it
basically and in that shat any question
purp in Bixby yeah I'd like to thank you
for putting this amendment together um I
think that um your description of Duties
is is um pretty covers the ground pretty
well uh I and I think that one can think
of all sorts of other things that one
might put into it but that would I think
that those are things that the committee
should be you know that that's the work
of the committee to do that so and one
of the things that I think that um is
important does not need to be in the
amendment but I think it's important to
consider with the committee is how do we
deal with making sure that uh law
enforcement is up to dat on changes in
statute because uh there have been
changes in the last few years in terms
of due process which not everyone would
have gotten in their two two-hour crash
course uh no matter you know how well
they remembered things so uh that that's
something that I think when we get the
committee up and running that should be
considered representative K uh thank you
representative bxby for that um in all
of this came out I asked each of the
stakeholders what they thought uh the
mission of this committee should be and
what was needed and I tried to
incorporate uh a consensus of that so
that it covered all areas so thank you
yeah thank you no this this is uh really
good and
um I think this is a
you know involved an involved
um
Mission um and not something that we
could just H hand to a subcommittee
right now to work on I think um this
study committee will uh you know will
need to take the time to to examine all
of these
points that being
said because
of situation that have happened
whatever I would like to draft a letter
on behalf of this committee to give to
our commissioner in the department of
safety um
to direct them to please contact or um
get some information out to the
Sheriff's departments and police State
Police whatever all of the law
enforcement arms to please have their
members review the cruelty
statutes um and because it it was
evident even in the testimony that uh
some of the law enforcement people just
didn't even know what the law is and I
think it would at least do something
immediately to have uh the commissioner
be aware that um at the very least U
members of his la enforcement uh
Community really do need to review what
current Law requires regarding due
process etc etc and rights of both the
animal owners and folks who are making
reports so uh representative kto and
then Penza thank you madam chair and and
thank you for that um during testimony
um the person representing the Chiefs uh
presented there's a uh they have a it's
like a
5x7 card laminated both sides um for
certain uh area of law enforcement and
she suggested maybe having something
like that that they could actually carry
in their vehicles um I don't know if
that would be the job of the the study
committee or that it would be the job
once the study committee is done uh
maybe having the governor's commission
work on that card um
with law enforcement to make sure that
um that something that so they can
automatically know where to go for a
reference and it could be simple as a QR
code that gives them the updated law
certainly would be a helpful resource
for them representative Penza um thank
you madam chair I was GNA say exactly
not about a letter but just I think that
was the biggest thing that was um taken
from the testimony was um just the
unknown aspect of the laws that are
currently on the books especially with
having to um contact the veterinarian
piece that was um that was really
important too um that was seemed to be
unknown as well so I think just stating
what they are and I I mean I can
understand it's just like here um
there's a lot of people that are
drinking from a fire hose and training
and that's one one day or half a day or
whatever it was that they're currently
getting for that to all be remembered
but um I think that that reminder would
be really good um because part of it is
some of the laws are great resources for
them that they might not be utilizing
right now and they should be so I I
think that's a letter and that reminder
however it can come out even through the
governor's commission that laminated
piece however it works I think there's a
lot of great ideas here that can help uh
law enforcement in this process thank
you anyone
else okay representative Scully
thank you um I think this is a great
idea S I think we've Dem um established
there's a demonstrated need but rather
in rushing into an approach that may
have unintended consequences I think
it's this is an excellent idea to study
this issue to make sure we we improve
upon um the current processes so we
don't have problems going forward um I
also I just thinking this through in
terms of the Advent of Technology too
I'm I'm wondering and of course this
could be looked at by the committee
whether this might be a good application
for um tele medicine to to have um
veterinaries uh available so that they
actually could be consulted in real time
if they couldn't necessarily be there to
to help screen the initial screen
process to make sure that there are less
incidences of um again uh the wrong
thing being done here so I think this
could also be looked at during the
committee process so I think this is an
excellent idea I will definitely be
voting for this okay thank you all
right okay I guess we can move along and
um I I will absolutely support this
amendment so thank you uh HB 171
establishing a moratorium on the
issuance of permits I'm sorry
representative guber uh yes thank you
madam chair uh that's the one that I
have an amendment for oh 1 171 yes oh
okay yeah so establishing a moratorium
for the issuance of permits for new land
Phils and representative Gruber you have
an
amendment
awesome awesome would you like to
explain this amendment thank you madam
chair um this amendment um uh was
written week ago there was uh from the
uh from the sponsor and co-sponsors they
also suggested one additional Amendment
that's not on here which is changing the
date from 5year moratorium to a
three-year Mor torum and so that
therefore uh I will have that tomorrow a
second amendment with that one date
changed so this is the amendment without
that one date changed okay and so the so
the date on the original uh bill is uh
2030 that would change to
2028 and make a three-year moror 8 so
this amendment uh uh just uh Mak uh
modifications as we discussed and I
think it's consistent with everywhere
everything we talked about here
um so in that we are expecting a CH an
amendment a different
Amendment um that would only change the
date that came um we would then recess
this we won't consider this for our exec
session this after uh this later this
morning
but instead do that when we come back
from vacation week uh yes or or if
tomorrow if you wish you we'll have it
we won't be executing any bills the next
thank sorry for the delay it was the
holiday yeah no I get it um certainly a
lot of amendments are are not going to
be ready because of uh yesterday's uh
day off representative
germana thank you madam chair I I wanted
to point a chest because it has been so
long since we've talked about this that
uh one of the tweaks that was made that
people may recall is a change to lines s
and 8 uh originally the the introduced
version said that uh the department
would not receive applications uh during
this moratorium this was changed to say
the department May accept applications
evaluate them for completeness and
request more information uh to make an
application complete so that was The
Tweak the original Bill said no
acceptance this amendment says they can
accept it and evaluate it only for
completeness that way at the end of a
moratorium period if there's an
application it's a complete application
that they can begin to uh evaluate so I
know we had discussed that I just wanted
to remind people because it feels like
it was a long time ago that we talked
about that okay does
um does the
moratorium also um include
expansions landfill expansions uh no the
mor moratorium in the specific the this
the amendment does not refer to any
expansions of of existing land it's only
for well yeah and if I may it's very
specifically excludes expansions in
section two lines right right okay I
didn't read that far thank
you okay cool all right so we are going
to put this one aside and um wait for uh
an amendment to the amendment for next
time okay so let me uh that'll be
recessed
okay
recessed all right um then we are at
hr13 opposing the permitting of a
landfill next to Forest Lake State Park
in Dalton New
Hampshire and uh I know that there was
an amendment that was proposed for that
representative germana uh thank you
madam chair yes we had this is another
one of those it's in the Pro the
amendment is in the process of being
amended uh we had um an amendment that I
worked on with representative King that
took it down to five
whereases um and then changed the
language around what was resolved
basically changing it from encouraging
these offices to use all legal Avenues
changed it to just resolved it as the
position of the house that there should
not be a uh okay a landfill I spoke uh
recently with representative coma um who
had concerns about one of the remaining
whereases and uh we I I have agreed that
uh we'll take that one out it's the
first one so we'll be down to four
whereases and um that will be back this
week so U there's no hurry obviously
because it's not well we can recess that
to uh March 4th as well that's fine so
we have three
bills that um I know uh HB 171 hr13 HB
307 that are um amendments will be
forthcoming and uh
so that uh that kind of is all that we
have for the work session for these
bills and so I'd like to take U maybe 10
minutes to just talk with uh um the
caucus to uh figure out who's making
what motions and where and then we can
reconvene at um
10:45 or a little bit after to uh work
on these Z bills so uh Democratic caucus
we'll just meet in the committee room
there are a couple of us missing today
so I think we'll all
fit okay
great yep uh anybody who's in the
audience here is going to need to step
out for 10 minutes or so please
h
e
e e
to open up the exec session for HB 49479
establishing a committee to study the
use and problems associated with
regulating the distribution and disposal
of certain Solid Waste within landfills
and transfer Centers do I hear a motion
representative
Penza yes um I'd like to make a motion
to itl HB 479 thank you do I hear a
second yes I would like to Second this
motion by representative okay
representative guber thank you for their
second and representative Penza would
you like to speak to your itl
motion yes uh the committee um the
committee knows that this bill was just
not necessary it doesn't it's not
something that needs to be studied we'd
already have um a very active Solid
Waste working group that will take this
under consideration and if there needs
to be any further legislation or um
action items um they will report back to
us thank you any discussion
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair I had a number of constituents
reach out to me about this because
they're concerned with the microplastics
that come from plastic bags um I just
want to say to them I share those
concerns it's just we don't need a study
committee in order to get that done
there's a number of ways to move forward
with plastic bags and dealing with the
microplastics problem without uh a study
committee this issue has been studied
pretty thoroughly so I agree with
representative Penza and I'll be voting
to itl this bill thank you represent vix
yeah I've uh had uh been read some
constituents have reached out to me
about this and they uh really strongly
support legislation to uh limit plastic
bags uh because of the various you
problems ranging from micro
microplastics to the interference with
uh the recycling system uh and they felt
that the solution of having the solid
waste working group uh work on it was
actually a better solution thank you uh
representative guber yeah I just want to
concur thank you uh Adam chair uh that
the um Plastics working group uh we had
dialogue too and this we all hope will
be the best most effective way forward
yep thank you and you know as a member
of the solid waste working
group first of all you know it was it
was evident from uh testimony that there
are folks out there who have and and
organizations who already have done an
enormous amount of research and I think
all of that research can easily be
brought to the attention of the solid
waste working group where there are
legislators like representative eel and
myself and uh Senator Pearl uh who can
take that information and um put
together some proposed
legislation um that that the uh house
can consider and the Senate can consider
another time so I I support this itl as
well I don't think that we have to uh
waste time with a a study committee
because all that research has already
been
provided so um with that if there are no
other questions or comments regarding uh
HB
479 uh I would like the clerk to call
the role on the itl
motion Vice chairwoman
ktoa representative Kenny
yes representative tenza
yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully yes
representative Barber
yes representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby
yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber
yes and chairwoman Aaron
yes uh 13 y zero Nays motion
passes okay thank
you and uh would we like to have that on
the consent calendar yes yes okay seeing
no objection uh please place that on the
consent calendar I'm going to close out
the exac on HB
479 and open up the exec on
hr10 and I would like to move um an
amendment to
hr10 uh uh 2025
d316
H do I hear a second for that
representative Penza yes I'd like to
second that motion for H1 and I will
speak to this um Amendment which all
have it a copy of um the amendment
changes the original bill um replacing
some wording uh we would make a
resolution saying whereas a clean and
healthy environment is important to and
impacts human health and whereas without
good health our ability to enjoy our
fundamental rights to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness is diminished
and now therefore be it resolved by the
House of Representatives we recognize
and highly value clean air clean water
and a healthy environment and we support
goals and policies that will promote
those values let it be further resolved
that copies of this resolution be sent
to members of the New Hampshire
Congressional Delegation the president
of the New Hampshire Senate and the
speaker of the New Hampshire House of
Representatives and that is the
amendment and I hope that you will
support it thank you questions comments
anybody would like to speak to the
amendment representative
germana thank you madam chair and I
won't Rec culate my speech I gave it
last time I'll only just say and
obviously I think it's a right and I and
I would say that I don't think a a lot
of my friends here would accept this
same level of commitment to the first or
second amendments of the United States
Constitution our right to free speech
and our our right to bear arms I don't
think that this level of of uh
resolution as much as I do applaud it
and will vote otpa when the when we get
there uh that again we we wouldn't
accept this level of support for the
other rights that we find
fundamental thank you any other
discussion with none I would like the um
the clerk to call the role for uh this
amendment to
hr10 Vice chairwoman comto
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative minor
yes ranking member Bixby
no Representative germana
no representative H Haskins
nay representative wheeler
n representative guber
nay and chairwoman Aon
yes 8 to five motion passes thank you I
would like to move um
otpa on uh
hr10 do I hear a second representative
germana
seconds and
um I I I would speak to the motion but I
think we've already heard everything so
uh I would request unless anybody else
has anything to say request the clerk to
call the role on hb1 uh
hr10 uh otpa
motion Vice chairwoman ktoa
yes representative Kenny
yes representative
Penza
yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully
yes repres representative Barber yes
representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber
yes chairwoman Aaron
yes 13 to nothing motion
passes okay
I and represent Bixby I'd be fine with
this being on consent okay I'd be fine
with it on consent as well
representative wheeler Madam chair I
have a question I I I know that my the
amendment is in my email I'm just
wondering if you have it available to
you in a paper copy so I could have the
number to the amendment that was just
passed to hr10 uh yes I
believe I can get that to you yes
I'll give you mine
here you're you're just looking for the
number
right consent calendar uh yeah I guess
uh we would put that on the consent
calendar unless I mean is that we can
read that in in the house or it doesn't
matter I think I think that it's
probably not a good use of time in the
house given what our calendar is going
to look like okay I'm good with it being
on consent it's
fine okay I'm going to close out
hr10 and open the exec session for
hp215 requiring a landfill permit
applicant to submit a report listing
potential harms and benefits of the
project uh do I hear a motion
representative germana thank you madam
chair uh I move Amendment
2025-the
25 okay do I hear a
second yes I'd like to second that um
that Amendment thank you representative
prenza and uh representative gero would
you like to speak to your motion yes
pardon me thank you madam chair uh what
this uh Amendment does is
to define the the concept of of net
public benefit when we are considering
landfill applications so to say that an
applicant has to demonstrate that the
proposed facility uh the The Proposal in
question the potential benefits outweigh
the potential harms uh we have defined
in this amendment the process whereby an
independent third-party contractor will
be brought in paid for by the applicant
to perform an assessment and how Dees
will use that assessment in order to
come to a preliminary determination
about public benefits if they determine
that there is uh that potential benefits
outweigh potential harms then the
proposal then goes forward for technical
review if they determine that the harms
outweigh potential benefits then the
applications would not proceed to
technical
review okay any other questions or
comments on that um
Amendment seeing none I'd like the uh
clerk to call the role on
Amendment uh uh 20250
H Vice chair woman ktoa yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins
I representative
wheeler representative Gruber
yes chairwoman Aaron
yes 130 motion passes okay great uh do I
hear a motion for
otpa representative germana thank you m
chair I move otpa on HB
215 do I hear a
second yes I second that represent Penza
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion representative germana uh yes
thank you madam chair so I already spoke
to uh the amendment which replaces
section one of the uh bill as introduced
and I would just point out two other
features of uh HB 215 that we've
discussed as as benefits here one is to
say that that when we're determining
benefit uh we are talking about one
location so an applicant cannot bundle
several locations and say well it's the
benefit of two or three things it is one
location that we'll be looking at uh and
then also the
bill defines a need more precisely the
state supreme court in late
2023 issued a ruling around how need was
defined and they said it's it's kind of
up to Dees to find under current statute
what this does uh is it kind of splits
the baby in half there were some folks
who said that uh an applicant would have
to demonstrate that there was capacity
need for every single day of the
lifetime of a facility folks in Industry
said no we should just have to
demonstrate need for a single day uh in
the proposed lifetime of a fa facility
this hopefully is the solomonian kind of
wisdom of uh splitting the uh splitting
the lifetime of the landfill in half so
you have to demonstrate that there is
Need for at least half of the permitted
lifetime of the facility
okay any other questions or comments
regarding that seeing none I'd like to
have the clerk call the role on the OTP
motion otpa motion for
hp215 vice chair Oman ktoa
yes representative Kenny
yes representative Penza
yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber yes ch Oman Aaron
yes 130 motion
passes
okay would we object to putting that on
consent that's fine all right on consent
it goes and I will close the exec on HB
215 which is great because that was an
early Bill
yay um I open the exact on HB 566
requiring permit applications for new
landfills to contain a detailed plan for
leech 8 management
do I hear a motion representative
germana thank you madam chair I move
Amendment
22542 n H2 HP
566 okay do I hear a second I I'll
second that there you
go would you like to speak to your
motion representative germana yes thank
you madam chair uh this amendment uh the
difference between what we have in front
of of us and the introduced bill is that
some language was moved out of the
contractual part at the bottom up into
the the management plan part at the top
and that was based on discussions with
Dees and with some representatives from
industry about what can and cannot be
required for
contracts uh and then we have also
Incorporated a couple of suggestions
from the solid waste uh subcommittee of
this committee uh to include uh the plan
would have to include a disc discussion
of any on site treatment of leech eight
and requiring contractual arrangements
with at least two facilities to be
provided with the
report okay great any other questions or
comments regarding this
amendment seeing none and if the clerk
is ready would you please call the role
on um this amendment
29h Vice chairwoman ktoa
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza
yes clerk votes
yes representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber
yes cheran Aaron
yes 130 motion passes okay thank you
very much I we'd like to put that on
consent we need now we need to do the
otpa oh I'm sorry duh uh okay um do I
hear a motion for otpa representative
gerana thank you madam chair I move otpa
on HP 566 I second that and I don't know
if you want to make any uh only very
briefly I want would to say we often
refer right to uh to what we do here is
the sausage making process um and I just
want to say that uh sweet or hot right
this one was sweet uh I do want to say
this was a really enjoyable experience
uh it was you know you can see from the
sponsorship it is bipartisan uh we had a
lot of great discussions a lot of great
feedback there was discussions with Dees
that was very helpful discussions with
members of the industry discussions with
some of our kind of environmental
activist friends so there are a lot of
cooks in this metaphor see uh a lot of
cooks in this particular kitchen but uh
I think this is a case actually where we
ended up with something really really
strong and I have hopes that uh this
bill can go far thank you I
concur uh any other discussion
seeing none would the clerk take the
roll call on otpa for HB
566 Vice chair Oman coma yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Penza yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber
yes representative Miner
yes ranking member Bixby
yes represent restive germana yes
representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative guber yes chairwoman
Aaron yes 130 motion passes thank
you and for your question yes it can go
into and that is another early bill so
I'm glad to have that off our plate and
I'm going to close out the exec for HB
566 and open up the exec for HB
153 requiring that two or more law
enforcement officers in each County
receive training regarding animal
cruelty do I hear a motion thank you
madam chair I would like to uh make a
motion to adopt uh amendment
2025-the
I hear a second representative I will
second that thank you would you like to
speak to your motion representative ktoa
uh thank you Madam chair I think most of
it's been said but I just wanted to um
recognize that this study CA committee
came about due to a
um an agreement a bunch through a lot of
different groups and that had a lot of
input into this and I think that this is
a great step forward in addressing a lot
of issues where we have holes uh dealing
with animal
cruelty okay any other further
discussion pres Bixby um this is the
second time second term that I've
co-sponsored a similar bill with
representative ktoa and uh last term it
didn't get very far this term uh I'm
glad that we got a lot of good feedback
on it and from our stakeholders and from
that feedback we figured out what we
really need to do as a study committee
and I applaud the way that
representative compa compa put together
that study
committee thank you um and then in
additionally um in tandem with this bill
going forward um I will be putting
together a a memo to the commissioner of
the Department of Safety asking them to
um direct their law enforcement people
to review the animal cruelty statutes uh
with regard to um due process and so
forth so um that'll be something that'll
H be happening as well
um with that all and no other discussion
I would direct the uh clerk to call the
role on adopting the amendment 2025
0443 Vice chairwoman coma
yes representative Kenny yes
representative
Penza
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative guber
yes chair ran Aaron
yes 130 motion passes okay do I hear a
motion for otpa representative ktoa
thank you madam chair I move uh HB
otpa okay and I will second that
representative Bixby thank you H
representative ktoa would you like to
make any comment on your motion I think
it's all been said all righty good
enough I would direct the uh clerk to
call the role on otpa for HB
153 Vice chairwoman compa yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Penza
yes clerk votes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber
yes representative Miner yes ranking
member Bixby
yes representative germana yes
representative H Haskins I
representative wheeler yay
representative Gruber yes chairwoman
Aaron yes 130 motion
passes thank you and uh do we have any
uh objection to putting that on consent
consent sounds good okay good uh I
should probably direct um this bill that
it be vacated from um Finance I think it
was supposed to go to finance
after or I don't know wherever it was
supposed to go should probably be
vacated I yeah so my guess is it
probably would have been going to
criminal justice but but it can be
I I think that it can be vacated because
is that a discussion that you have with
the chair of that
committee yeah I will I will follow up
on that because they may not need to
hear that yeah okay cool does that mean
consent calendar or a consent calendar
yeah but also I would have to follow up
with where it was supposed to go next
since it's a study
committee okay any other comment
question I will now close the uh exec
session on hb1 153 and open the oh I'll
open uh the exec session for HB
171 and I am going to propose that we uh
recess the exec session for March 4th at
10:30 in the morning because we have an
amendment forthcoming that is not ready
and uh we can't really take action on
that everybody agree yep okay I'm
recessing this to March 4th at 10:30 and
closing the exec on HB
171 I am going to open up the exec
session for HB uh
hr13 opposing the permitting of a
landfill next to Forest Lake State Park
in Dalton New Hampshire and I am also
going to recess the vote uh the exec on
this for March 4th at 10:30 in the
morning because again we have an
amendment forthcoming for this HR Bill
and um without objection from
anybody I am going to recess this bill
I'm closing the exact session on
hr13 and opening the exec session on
hb150 enabling Homestead operations to
use commercial kitchen equipment in
preparing food for sale do I hear a
motion representative ktoa thank you
madam chair I would like to make a
motion uh to adopt Amendment
420h
okay uh do I hear a second on that
Amendment um I second that Madam chair
who oh representative
wheeler okay thank you for that
uh do You' like to speak to your motion
representative
ktoa thank you madam chair um it's a
very simple change the original wording
uh in the bill the original bill was uh
making sure that the equipment was able
to be washed and rinsed and uh after
listening to testimony we felt it was
more appropriate to say to be cleaned
and sanitized because we know that
sanitizing
uh and everything in a work area is
extremely important for food
safety okay any other further discussion
on this
bill seeing none I'd like the clerk to
call the role on adopting the amendment
d420 for
hb150 vice chair woman comto
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza
yes clerk votes yes yes representative
Scully yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner yes ranking member
Bixby
yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins
I representative wheeler yay
representative guber yes chairwoman
Aaron yes 130 motion
passes thank you
uh I do I hear a motion for otpa
representative uh ktoa thank you madam
chair I would like to move uh the
adoption of
hb150 with the amendment uh 20250 42h so
otpa okay thank you do I hear a
second I second that Madam chair
representative wheeler too busy
writing thank you representative
wheeler uh would you like to speak to
your motion I think it's all been okay
it's all been said any other question
comment thank you very much I asked the
uh clerk to call the role for otpa on
hb150 Vice chair Omen coma
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Penza yes clerk votes yes
representative Scully
yes representative Barber yes
representative Miner
yes ranking member big
yes representative germana
yes representative H Haskins I
representative wheeler yay
representative guber yes chairman Aon
yes 130 motion
passes thank you and uh do I hear any
objection for this to be put on consent
I think that's good okay put this on the
consent calendar as
well thank you
and I am going to close out the exec for
hb150 open up the exec for HB
307 um this is another bill which we
have an amendment forthcoming so we are
unable to exec it today and I am going
to recess the exec for this bill to
March 4th at 10:30 in the morning
without objection from
anyone and um I'm going to close out the
EXA for HB
307 and that finishes and concludes our
exec sessions for um for these six 78 n
bills and I appreciate all your time and
work and we finished early my goodness
we've got some
time uh I don't know if there's any uh
committee business that we need to
discuss at this
time sure representative ger I'm curious
we made great progress today with three
of our FN uh so early bills I'm just
wondering what's our our total where do
we stand on our early bills in terms
we're done with our early
bills yay we had six and we're done with
them and I'm going to remind our uh the
folks who uh made motions on these bills
to get your committee reports into me so
I have representative Penza for HB
479 I have me for
hr10 uh representative germana for
hp215 I have representative germana
again for HB
566 representative ktoa for HB
153 and uh representative ktoa for hb150
as
well and as usual if uh you can get them
to me this evening that would be great I
don't wish to hunt you down to
get them if necessary all right well
we're good we're we're just cruising
Along on these
um we have three bills that we're going
to hear this
afternoon um I am expecting a a larger
than usual crowd for our
2:00 uh hearing on HB
396 um and then tomorrow we are meeting
and we will will discuss the three bills
plus hb77 if we have any updates on that
um at 9:30 in the morning uh we will be
hearing a bill what one two three four
five bills tomorrow and again the last
one um in the
afternoon should be uh um a longer than
usual hearing I don't know I'm I'm
expecting there will be some comment on
HB
152 yeah yeah yeah um and and I I did
get your email representative H Haskins
regarding the committee uh researcher
report on HB
152 regarding glue traps uh your comment
is um has been noted that
um you felt that it was deficient in um
certain points of um support for the
bill
um I am not uh requesting the committee
researcher to make any amendments or
changes to that because it's kind of
already too late to do it but
um I I appreciate that you've made some
comments I don't know if you wanted to
say a few words about it well just for
clarification um I was concerned that
the um report that you forwarded to the
committee was incomplete in that it did
not uh say that our own fish and game
department is opposed to these glut trap
bills and that the bill is silent to the
issue of insect mitigation so it
shouldn't appear that it's being swept
up in the bill because rodents are the
only noun that is included in the bill
okay that is duly noted and and uh I
hope the
committee um understands your your
position on that representative Miner
thank you madam chair I don't uh I
suspect that all of you are much like
myself have received well over a hundred
bul emails on this issue so it's a it's
a hotly contested issue and it um
certainly should be exciting yeah you
know I'm I'm waiting to hear uh all the
testimony that will be presented to us
tomorrow and um representative kto and
then representative Penza you have some
comments thank you madam chair
[Music]
um I wish people when the there's so
many bulk emails coming in support of
this it's not that it's easy to push a
button to to from a group to do that um
unfortunately um I'm will be absent for
the hearing tomorrow tomorrow um but I
guess when we have our work session I
will discuss My Views
uh
then okay and I do have a copy uh hard
copy I know I sent it out electronically
but I also do have a hard copy of the uh
the report uh that uh our committee
researcher Christy uh a freser had
prepared regarding the the glue trap um
bill so I'll pass it along and you can
review it before tomorrow I'm sorry
represent Penza yeah no just uh quick I
I appreciate um you asking the committee
researcher for that information I think
it was helpful I did have a question and
it might have been I've already
previewed um that not readit you know
cover to cover but I've spent a decent
amount of time on the report I just
wanted to understand is this the is this
the second time that this bills come
forward to my knowledge yes okay um
and then um my other question is I
haven't reviewed is this the exact same
I haven't looked at you know last term
in this term is is exactly the same bill
or has I don't know does anybody know
that was it just a
refile Linda substantially the same a
little bit of Cleanup in the language
but the essence of the bill is quite
similar to last session
Bill okay okay thank you all right with
that uh we get to have an extra half
hour for lunch and uh we'll see you
later at 1
o'clock and thank you for all your time
and work this
morning if I could just stay here and
manage my Pap that would be something
but I need to go to to the break yes
exactly hopefully if you step away from
it for a little bit you can you know
make better
sense
e
e e
good afternoon I'd like our members to
please take their seats um we're about
to get underway with our Committee
hearing for HB 505
okay are you all set yeah
okay all right good afternoon welcome to
environment and agriculture committee
and we have with us uh to
present um h505 I'm going to open up the
hearing for
HB
505 which is allowing the sale of
freeze-dried foods produced in Homestead
food operations and with us this
afternoon to introduce the bill is the
esteemed representative Tom shamberg we
are fortunate to have you with us good
afternoon thank you madam chair and
thank you members of the environment
agricultural committee I am
representative Tom shamberg I serve on
the house Ways and Means Committee uh I
represent the towns of wilmet and Sutton
in maram County district 6 as Madame
chair has said this is House Bill 505 is
to allow the sale of freeze-dried foods
produced in Homestead operations the
request for this bill came from Donna
and Dave Bates of bog Mountain Retreat
and Suites and wilmet who are sitting
behind me back here they operate under
the New Hampshire Homestead Cottage laws
in producing freeze-dried candies they
wish to expand their business operation
by doing freeze dried ice cream thus
this piece of legislation the purpose of
this legislation is to amend the
homestead cottage law regulations within
the New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services for smallscale food
businesses that produce both non
perishable and perishable food products
including freeze dried items in
residential kitchens as you can see
under Roman numeral one letter B lines
11 and 12 on page one of the
bill now I lost my place
uh these are foods that are considered
potentially hazardous foods because they
are temperature control for safety TCS
Foods there's a list of which milk and
dairy products are included but with
specialized freeze-dried process these
Foods under the TCS definition would
become non-temperature control for
safety as they can be safely kept at
room temperature and do not require
refrigeration thus the added statement
amending RSA 143 capital a colon
to be included under Roman numeral 1B
food that is freeze dried shall not be
considered potentially hazardous food
and then under Roman numeral 4 that
begins on page
one at line
26 and the sentences we're looking at
are four and five the additional
requirement for food safety standards
regarding packaging of freeze dry foods
that were once perishable and are now
shelf stable must contain the
appropriate oxygen absorbers for sale
and shall contain the additional label
not for purposes of rehydrating the
proposed legislation establishes an
amendment for the homestead license in
New Hampshire for freeze drying
businesses allowing them to produce both
perishable and non- perishable foods
including freeze-dried items and dairy
products like ice cream in residential
kitchens the aim is to provide freeze
drying business with flexibility to
freeze dry perishable and non-
perishable foods while ensuring consumer
safety I do hope that the environment
and agricultural committee will approve
this amending of the present RSA so that
it better represents this new freeze
dried drying cottage industry that is
providing an expansion of our state's
economic base for more technical aspects
of this freeze dried cottage industry I
will defer to my constituents Donna and
Dave Bates from Wilmont for answering
any of your technical
questions I deal with
numbers thank
you thank you representative shamberg we
really appreciate that um representative
King thank you madam chair and thank you
for uh testifying today so my
understanding is that there's nowhere in
statute that labels freeze-dried fruit
uh food as hazardous it's in the rules
right and that if we pass this then the
Department's going to have to change
their rules to better reflect that is
that what happens yes it is
represent thank you any other questions
from the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much representative shamberg for
bringing this bill to
us and I have uh Donna
bats hello I'm so nervous to be here but
very grateful for this opportunity um we
have a small please first just introduce
yourself and where you from and and also
I must also say that we are not allowed
to use props in our presentations okay I
mean you know we can explain a process
or something but placards and props are
not really supposed to be used in the
committee room I'm sorry no that's fine
um so I'm Donna Bates I'm from Wilmont
and we have a small um freeze drying
business did is everything okay oh I'm
sorry
go ahead I'm sorry go ahead um and we
um sorry I got thrown
off we U have come across some obstacles
so we are allowed to do candy only at
the moment any kind of candy that's not
perishable um when you freeze dry food a
temperature control food like ice cream
which you all have in front of you um it
turns it into a
um a shelf stable food so all the
bacteria 99.9% of it is taken out of
that food with that moisture is taken
out during the process um so it makes it
safe um and we would just like to so at
the moment we have our uh Homestead
Cottage license which allows us to do
the candy but if we'd like to expand
which we really need to to ice cream and
maybe to some other like yogurt for kids
and things like that we would be
required to do a commercial kitchen
which requires us to do three sinks a
mop syn a whole different protocol the
trays that we use are very small um when
we use parchment paper there's little to
no residue left over at all um for
bacteria's sake to be cleaned again we
use new parchment paper there's a whole
protocol that you can follow um which we
had suggested that maybe there's a
compromise that we could just present a
protocol and be able to do different
foods um singly uh it just felt like
trying to do a commercial kitchen in our
house just didn't really make sense with
what we were trying to do it seemed a
little bit extreme and costly um a lot
of the candy manufacturers have now seen
how successful we have been and they are
now doing their own candy so Skittles
for example is doing their own and it's
it's causing a hit um but a lot of the
larger companies won't do ice cream or
yogurt or things like that so it would
give us a chance to be able to expand
Within the same cleanly kitchen that we
already use for our candy the same
systems apply um but we' be able to do
more and not have to have that
expense okay questions from the
committee representative
wheeler thank you Don and thank you for
being here you did well it's not as
nerve-wracking as it seems we're all
regular people but I do just wanted
to know more about the freeze drying
process and what it's like to freeze dry
an item and then also say thank you for
those freeze dried Skittles I've had
them they're good so tell us more about
freeze drying please okay so the process
is pretty controlled um it's a machine
that looks like a small beverage um dorm
size refrigerator we have two of them um
and there's different trays different
sizes but we just have medium ones so
it's very small controlled um and the
trays are about the size of a cookie
sheet if I could show you one I would
um but they're um very manageable and
you put the food that you want to freeze
dry or the candy in this case on the
tray we wear gloves and masks and do we
have certain um sanitizer we're required
to use on all of our countertops um but
you put the food into the freeze dryer
there's certain settings for different
things they make it really easy so we
literally know that ice cream needs to
be set at -20 for initial freeze time
and it's already programmed for the
amount of hours that you need you can
add extra dry time to make sure that
you're being really thorough um but it's
all pretty much set up for you um from
the companies with the freeze dryers
that we use they're considered a
professional grade within your home um
so it's a vacuum chamber and what it
does is it initially freezes the food
then it vacuum seals it and then it
Heats it up to whatever temperature is
in the protocol that you've set so for
example candy is 150 um food is usually
125 for the heat draws out all of the
moisture so all that's left once we
defrost the machine is like this much
water in the bottom of a five gallon tub
that goes through a hose and the food
comes out crunchy like you'll see the
ice cream so it's taken out all of the
moisture from the food or
99.99% of the moisture as long as you
keep it sealed in a myar bag with an
oxygen absorber um it will stay in the
state that it's intended to stay
in traditionally you can freeze dry food
I mean it's been done since the 1900s um
and you might have heard of Patriots
Foods or astronaut ice cream NASA sent
this up um because it's lightweight and
they're able to eat it and still have
that kind of taste of different foods we
freeze Dr for our own sake you know
different everyday foods to eat at
snacks um and it just it's just a it's
just a different way of preserving food
but it's been done for a really long
time
safely
okay represent representative germana
did you have a question uh
representative wheeler asking so thank
you okay
fine okay uh representative kto thank
you madam chair and thank you very much
for bring being here and bringing this
important issue to uh the Forefront just
a quick question for you um now freeze
drying doesn't have to be done
just in a freeze-dried piece of
equipment it could be done other ways is
that
correct using the equipment is the only
way I know about doing it safely with
certain protocols and so that that's the
only way I know of follow follow up yeah
so I guess I'm I'm I'm just going to air
on the side of um looking at public
health and I understand that a
freeze-dried machine is really measures
the the content of the humidity and the
moisture and everything like that but if
we just put in that you can freeze dry
Foods at home then you could actually
use your oven or some other means of
doing that I believe I'm just looking
here online uh that people can use other
methods do you think it should say that
it must be done with appropriate
equipment that is a great idea
absolutely thank
you okay I have a question about so the
types of food that you've been doing is
pretty much candy ice cream yogurt that
kind of thing I'm allowed to sell candy
I do ice cream and food for family and
friends if I'm not selling it um or as
thank you presents the teachers at my
kids school love it so I can do it as
thank yous but I can't sell it right um
so yes so what about um freeze-dried
fruit freeze dried Meats I would love to
be able to do freeze-dried fruit but
there's also in the law a whole protocol
where you have to take it and write down
a protocol and and send it to Cornell
for testing um because there's not
anything that can be done um in New
Hampshire and it's just a very very
lengthy process so we haven't pursued
that yet um but there is a process that
you could do to apply for it is that
part of the um recipe review thing or is
this is something different it's
something different that we wish as
freeze dryers in our home business we
wish we could just freeze dry bananas
and strawberries because we're taking
the moisture out and therefore
eliminating the threat of the bacteria
and as long as you put not for the
purposes of rehydrating you're not
introducing any threats back into it so
we should be able to do it just like
we're doing Candy our our kitchens are
clean they're inspected we have certain
protocol we have to follow it's no
different whether it's a tray of
Skittles or Taffy or whether it's a tray
of strawberries you're still taking the
same moisture out your trays still have
the same residue on them you still
follow the same protocols that's what's
frustrating is that just by having us go
through all the Hoops of a commercial
kitchen that requires so much I mean
you're talking a food processing plant
is what they're asking us to do for what
we just want to do on little trays if
that makes sense and so you've been
making these items the ones that is not
legal uh for family and friends as gifts
has anybody been sick from that no and
um so we originally during covid um
looked into different freeze-dried foods
that we purchased from Patriots food um
but I have a lot of food allergies and
so while the family could have them and
it be safe um there was nothing I could
eat and so we looked into freeze dryers
so that I could actually freeze dry food
that would be safe for me to eat uh and
so we've been freeze drying since 2020
um we just opened up a package of turkey
from two years ago and turned it into
turkey salad and it was an amazing lunch
um we have lots of relatives that do it
in Utah and we have other friends that
have since bought freeze dryers and they
make freeze-dried food for themselves
now and no one's ever gotten sick again
you're you're using the same protocol
that you would use if you were cooking
for yourself
or if you were going to eat ice cream
out of a bowl and then go sit on the
couch it literally takes me less time to
take it from the freezer to the tray to
a cold Frozen machine than it what than
it would be for you watching your ice
cream sitting on your coffee table so
all the same protocols for safety are
there you're just putting it in a
machine and it's taking out the moisture
which has the potential to have bacteria
in it so and I have one last question
and then if anybody else has a questions
I don't mean to be hogging the time but
um if you were to be able to sell these
other items that you're seeking to make
legal um how much do you think that
would increase your income for your
business lifechanging honestly we're
really really at a standstill when we
first started this a year ago and we
were looking into how popular the ice
cream was we had over 150 emails asking
me if I could sell them the ice cream
when we said we were thinking about
doing it and I had to say no to every
single one of them and direct them to
other people online from different
states that can sell it so there's I I
still get requests every day every week
for people wanting to know if I could
sell the ice cream and I can't unless I
go through the all the Hoops of a
commercial kitchen and honestly I would
never use three sinks to wash one little
tray it just it doesn't make sense for
the flow okay thank you representative
King thank you madam chair thank you for
taking
questions if you have any kind of food
that um is left out to rot um and then
it's not necessarily the that bacteria
you'd be worried about I would imagine
it would be the toxins left behind by
the bacteria if you if you were to
freeze dried if you were to freeze dry
food that already had toxic buildup in
it I mean would it then be safe or would
it it it would then be so how how does
how do you how do you maintain the
safety of freeze-dried food just like
you do with freeze-dried candy I'm not
going to have you know I wouldn't spray
my Skittles with toxic cleaner and then
put them in the freeze dryer and sell
them to people I'm not going to take ice
cream that's been sitting out on the
counter for an hour and then freeze dry
it it's the common sense protocol of
what would you do and whether I had a
commercial kitchen or my residential
kitchen the protocol is still going to
be the same I'm still going to take
caution and prepare everything as if I
were serving it to my own child so that
if there's bacteria on it just like if
you were to go to a restaurant and
somebody sneezes on the food or bacteria
gets into it and you eat it you're still
going to get sick you can only prevent
so much but the process of freeze drying
between either a residential k or a
commercial kitchen is the exact same
process does that make sense I think so
I have to think about that thank you
okay representative Miner thank you
madam chair thank you for taking
questions let me ask you a question are
are you an
LLC um no we're just to DBA uh do you
have insurance for we do we have a lot
of insurance perfect thank you which we
could also require of people that wanted
to sell it if that needed to be in there
I absolutely think that would be a
requirement most um companies that
freeze dry even with can candy it's
recommended and a lot of the stores
won't want you to sell it unless you
have insurance oh that's very true so
it's one of the very first things that
we did and it doubled our insurance so
being able to expand what we can sell
would be really helpful right
now representative
Scully thank you Madame chair do you
make your own ice cream is is this a a
process you do all the way or you buy it
from other people no I buy a tmook
usually is the one that I buy it's one
that's the most recommended it's what
everyone has today it has really more
natural clean ingredients and not a lot
of the extra synthetic stuff in it um I
don't want to make my own ice cream
because that would just open up a whole
another can of worms and put more strain
on systems which we're trying not to do
we're trying to keep it really really
simple which is why we even use
parchment paper during our process so
that we don't have any extra fat or
anything else going into our
system a followup please followup y all
right so then when you make your
freeze-dried ice cream are you carrying
over the list of ingredients that are in
the original ice cream putting that
that's what's on the back of your
package right straightly from the telok
website okay thank you anyone else have
questions seeing none thank you very
much and we appreciate you uh coming and
talking to us today and thank you
letting us know what the process is and
how your business works thank you
appreciate it I'd like to call um Erica
Davis and Michelle Roberge from DHHS
food
protection oh um for the speakers that
have already come uh represent shamberg
and
um oh yeah and Donna Bates if you have
written testimony we would appreciate it
um forwarded up to our our clerk thank
you
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record my name is Michelle
Roberge I'm the bureau chief for public
health protection uh within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and division of Public Health Services
and with me today is Erica Davis and
she's the food protection section
administrator within the division of
Public Health Services and we'll be
providing the testimony
today thank you members of the committee
for the opportunity to speak today on
House Bill
505 um so this bill would amend the
definition of potentially hazardous
foods um to state that F freeze-dried
foods would not be considered
potentially
hazardous currently the department does
not allow for I need you to speak up a
little bit y currently the department
does not allow for freeze died Foods in
a homestead food operation and those are
freeze-dried non or potentially
hazardous foods we do allow non-
potentially hazardous foods to be
freeze-dried in a homestead food
operation freeze drying is a specialized
process whereby by the water activity of
the product is reduced to a point where
it does not allow harmful micro
organisms to grow freeze drying
potentially hazardous
products I'm
sorry um takes a product through a
drying process to bring the water
activity low enough again so that
there's no no room for growth of harm
from
microorganisms if the process is not
done properly it can leave a product
unsafe to where microorganisms can
grow due to safety concerns of this
process it is important that the product
is evaluated by a processing authority
to set the parameters by which the
process can be done
safely it also should be conducted in a
commercial facility using commercial
equipment Homestead food operations
operations are not required to use
commercial equipment and by expanding
these types of potentially hazardous
foods to be allowed in a homestead
kitchen there is concern that the
equipment may not be adequate to produce
a consistent and safe
product the bill would also require that
freeze-dried foods contain the
appropriate oxid oxygen absorber when
packaged these parameters are not set by
the department these are generally laid
out by a processing processing Authority
who has looked at the process and the
product that wants that is is being
produced to evaluate the safety
parameters that need to be met to create
a safe
product the department would like to
also share that in 2013 we did have a
outbreak associated with dried meat
products it was a dehydrated meat
product but the process of dehydration
and the process of freeze drying are
similar by where why whereby you're
reducing the water activity create to
create a safe product
there were 43 people who became ill with
salmonella um from chicken jerky pet
treats um that were sold and produced
from a home
kitchen thank you and I'm happy to
answer any
questions and I'll just add that we did
provide you with the case information so
you should have our testimony and then
um a a summary of the case information
so this case happened 11 years ago
2013 okay um representative King thank
you madam chair uh two Qui questions you
said um it was people that got sick from
chicken jerky pet treats so they were
eating dog food or I don't know they
were handling they handled pet treats oh
they okay so the people that made the
chicken jerky were also handling pet
treats and that's how so the the chicken
jerky was a pet treat okay so they were
creating pet treats out of chicken okay
so they dehydrated it and it was
dehydrated improperly so it allowed for
the grow of growth of salmonella in
which the handling of the treat then
spread food born elness wow okay thank
you and then my other uh quick question
is are is the department neutral on this
bill or is it against it is there a
stance so we're neutral but we wanted to
present our serious concerns with
respect to this okay thank you this
spell representative H Haskins thank you
madam
chair would you entertain the thought
that if a step towards allowing people
who have been safely producing food in
their home kitchen to expand to
something like yogurt and ice
cream as a step forward perhaps in time
other freeze dried foods could be
entered in into the statute would you be
more comfortable with
that so the
concern I know we we talked a lot about
ice cream and
yogurt
um we're not the ones that determine
those safety
parameters um we really rely on science
we really rely on these food processing
authorities who can give us the
parameters so the food processors
processing authorities will look at all
steps of the process and the product so
they're going to look at it from start
to finish they're going to look at the
recipe they're going to look at the
process and then they're going to look
at the final process uh product I'm
sorry to make sure that they've hit each
of these
parameters to to give a blanket
statement that that these products are
okay but these products aren't it's hard
for it's not something that we can
determine okay we really rely on that
processing authority to give us those
details quick followup if I may sir so
if we were to pass this bill and it
became law um people who have been
safely producing food in their home
kitchen like candy um would have the
opportunity to expand and there would be
an inspection all the kinds of protocols
that they've sub been subject to all
along and we would have data um to
inform future decisions about
expanding freeze dried foods Would we
not we would for for those specific
items however this gives the opening the
definition to non or to potentially
hazardous products opens the door to not
just dairy or milk products or yogurt
unless we amended the bill correct it
would open it up to any non-p
potentially ha products so you're
talking meat products
um any any food product really um that
is potentially hazardous could be
freeze-dried in the homestead
kitchen thank you represent Bixby and
then we're going to go over to Miner
yeah so um we heard testimony that uh
freeze drying of fruits would not be
allowed uh and I'm are fruits
potentially H hazardous um food when
they're just you know if you like pick
an apple from your tree is that a
potentially hazardous fruit uh food they
can be it depends on the the ph and
water activity of the product
so depending
on it depends on the product okay so I
I'm I'm just going so so would would I
be
would
uh are you
would root that is just picked off from
a tree be allowed to be S sold under our
current
statutes just picked off a tree yes
that's it's whole produce okay so whole
produce that hasn't been processed any
further is allowed to be sold as is as
soon as you take um a a whole produce
and you continue to process it by
cutting it then it becomes it falls to
to food
protection okay so so uh actually
selling cut apples would not be allowed
under current law under Homestead no
okay so you need to have a commercial
kitchen to do that correct okay thank
you representative Miner thank you madam
chair the case study that you refer to
is 2013 that as uh chairman um Aaron is
indicated it's well over 13 years ago
would you agree that standards have
changed and Equipment has changed the
technology has
changed I I don't know that I can speak
to that yes I I'm sure things have come
a long way since then so would you Al
followup followup so would you also
agree that probably back in 2013 the
equipment that was used is probably not
as um good as
today I don't know that I can speak to
that but there is a difference um there
are differences between um commercial
equipment and non commercial equipment
and the concern would be that if they're
not using commercial equipment it may
not produce a
consistently um dried product thank you
representive kalk thank you madam chair
and thank you for being here and
testifying just a quick look at this
case study that where uh individuals
were harmed from semilla I noticed that
it has to do with a
dehydrator we're talking about and there
is a difference between a dehydrator in
a freeze-dried machine for Freez drying
Foods um So based on
that did was this actually using a
freeze dryer or just a dehydrator thank
you for the question it it was a
dehydrator there is a difference between
freeze drying and dehydrating however
the safety parameters is reducing the
water activity they're just doing it in
two different ways one's using heat and
one's doing using freeze drying follow
up thank you madam chair and thank you
again for taking my question but because
a freeze dried machine not a dehydrator
actually monitors moisture content
vacuum seals and other things I think
it's a very specific piece of equipment
and I don't think it can be compared to
a dehydrator and I think from that point
of view this is how we have to look at
this piece of legislation because we're
looking at and making sure and if we add
in that they're using the proper machine
a freeze-dried machine and not a
dehydrator or an oven I think would make
it much
safer okay representative
King oh did you want to reply to that I
was just going to mention that um these
types of processes whether it's freeze
drying or uh dehydration these are
specialty processes and really a
processing Authority is is is necessary
to make sure that the equipment is
appropriate that the process is used and
and um the you know looks at the entire
process so these are not something that
is generally we can set General
Provisions for this is done through a
scientific review such as a process
Authority at Cornell um or other
processes process authorities at I think
there's one in Maine as well so this is
a you know not a just because it's a
piece of equipment doesn't mean that
this isn't a specialty process and could
um by not following proper procedures
could introduce some foodborn illness
concerns thank you representative King
you had a question yeah thank you again
Madam chair um I'm just trying to wrap
my head around the concern
here for hazardous foods there for
homesteaders making hazardous foods and
selling hazardous foods there's a
there's a higher standard for the
processing right so for example you know
if you're if you're butchering meat or
something you're going to need you're
going to need to meet a much higher
standard and the concern is that people
who don't meet that higher standard for
say butchering meat out of their home
they're going to be able to sort of get
around that standard by just saying okay
well I can't sell it as fresh meat but
I'll just sell it as freeze-dried meat
and so you might have people you know
butchering meat in their in their uh in
their garage and the garage can't be the
the walls and the ceilings can't be
washed and so you've got this kind of
Chop Shop of like filth and but they can
get around it by Fe freeze drying it and
I think there's a little bit of a
confusion here because the process of
freeze drying um in and of itself may be
safe but if if the food was contaminated
before you even freeze dry it you've
still got a problem with the toxins that
have built up the freeze drying might
kill the bacteria but it's not going to
it's not going to neutr uze the toxins
that are in there so am I understanding
this correctly is that your
concern thank you for the question so
yes there are concerns because you're
taking a potentially hazardous product
and through the process of freeze drying
you're turning it into a non-
potentially hazardous product which is
the same thing you would do in a retail
facility the cooking um chicken you cook
it to 165
to make sure that it's safe for
consumption this specialized
process isn't measured by just
temperature it's time it's temperature
it's equipment it's how um how you cut
and process the product that's going
into the freeze dryer so if you don't
meet those steps in between you can
leave the end product which you're
assuming is a non-tcs product or a non
potentially hazardous product and you
may have missed reducing the water
activity enough in the process to allow
it to be safe in the end followup follow
up okay but my my specific concern isn't
so much about the water content and
whether or not whether or not that will
inhibit bacterial growth my my concern
really is that this idea that there
might be people that are doing something
unsanitary before even the freeze-dried
process starts the food gets
contaminated with toxins and then it
just get freeze dried and the toxins are
still there that's my concern is that
your concern as well
so it's it's the pro it's in the process
so if
[Music]
we I if you if you missed step on water
activity yes there can be room for micro
organisms to grow once it's been
freeze-dried representative Bixby
representative com um I'm so I'm trying
to figure out where where the line is
where something goes from unaccept
acceptable to
unacceptable uh
so if
uh so is it the case that if you start
out with a uh a a food that is non uh um
non-hazardous and you freeze dry it that
is just okay
so uh for example if I made blueberry
jam and I freeze DED it then that would
be just
fine uh but if I did say
blueberry yogurt that would be
problematic is that Thea is that the
case yes than because the yogurt part is
the is the potentially hazardous
food if I may follow up on
representative King's question so so um
if there were particular toxins in a
product um that you're referring to that
the the act of freeze drying certainly
wouldn't remove any tox toxins from the
product they would remain in there if
that helps your if that helps answer
your question okay representative ktoa
and then Miner thank you madam chair and
and thank you so as I'm listening here
and as I listened to uh testimony
earlier it seems like what they're doing
is they're buying already food that is
processed and
acceptable and then they're taking that
and freeze drying it so if we put in
there that it's already processed food
then it should be allowed to be
freeze-dried in a freeze-dried machine
not a dehydrator I think um we're
getting in the weeds when we're talking
about you know chicken that's uncooked
they're we're actually talking about
food that is readily
already there on the shelf and they're
just bringing it into the home and
freeze drying it um so
please
so and thank you for for it's not a
question but thank you for that um uh
statement I I would I would add that the
act of freeze drying can introduce if
it's not done correctly it can introduce
um microorganisms into the products so
even though the product may not have
microorganisms and you can correct me if
I'm wrong um may not have
microorganisms at the start the ACT if
it's not done correctly then and and
determined by a process Authority that
is not the Department of Health and
Human Services that does that or nor has
the expertise to do that then it can
render the product there could be um
toxins and it's exactly what happened in
the case that we
presented you know we shared with you is
that the product had allowed for growth
of Sal Manila and then sickened people
who became exposed to it so that's the
Department's concern is it's the actual
act act of the process that if not done
correctly could introduce um you know
concerns okay representative
Miner representative ger thank you madam
chairman wouldn't you would don't you
agree that the iron speaks loud here
where uh Kil and Tyson and uh
SBA a month doesn't go by when when
their food isn't recalled for some sort
of botulism or some sort of salmonella
we're talking about a small Homestead
operation here I think we're I think
we're really looking at over over
regulating this do you
agree no I I don't just because the the
the process itself the active freeze
drying is if not done correctly can add
uh can introduce forood born
illness quick
followup I asked earlier um um the
people that own the homestead and I'm
sorry I can't remember I don't recall
her name that owns the store they have
insurance they have saf guards in place
in case of uh an accidental
um poisoning let's
say so the question is do you agree that
that would be enough um safeguard for
this type of
operation thank you for that um our
concern in public health is to prevent
foodborn illness so we're not looking at
a reactive approach to this we're trying
to take a proactive approach um in in
limiting what's being
done what products are being done in
with this specialized product process to
ensure that there is no food born
illness so we we really want to take
that um proactive approach
representative germana thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so the phrase I've heard you say a
number of times which seems to me key in
all of this is if not done correctly and
so could you speak to the difference
between the type of equipment that might
be used in a commercial facility as
opposed to the kind of equipment that
one might buy for a home operation and
how the difference between those might
account for something not being done
correctly because I can see a situation
where if you're buying a piece of
equipment to do this in your home and it
is on kind of the lower end of of
expense it's not a commercial grade
freeze dryer that it may not hit the
target it might tell you that it hits
the target that it has removed all of
the moisture that needs to be removed
but presumably the kinds that are used
in commercial operations are more
accurate when it comes to being able to
to to measure that so could you speak to
the difference between the kinds of
equipment used in commercial operations
versus other kinds that may not be as
good at verifying that the process has
been done
correctly yes thank you for that I will
I will will do my best um
so the difference would be the intent so
for home residential equipment the
intent is for um production on a on a
smaller scale for you know home home
production when you are looking to sell
at retail they
they're the intent is
that commercial um the size so the and
the intent of the sale so we there are
standards that commercial equipment need
to to meet to make sure that um the
intent of um the use of
the commercial equipment
is
proper um Can can I add to that um so
yes I think I think the equipment
differs in terms of its capabilities and
the other part which I I I can't stress
enough is the process itself is unique
for each food product so understanding
how long how long you keep it in there
what the temperature is or you know the
the entire looking at the entire process
to make sure that the food is processed
appropriately that really needs to go
through a process Authority that the
department does not have the expertise
to look at every whether you're freeze
drying a piece of fruit or freeze drying
a piece of meat or freeze drying you
know whatever the product is those are
not uniform so we can't set uniform
standards in rule or law that looks at
each every and and applies it evenly
across across the board to say it's safe
it really is dependent on the product at
hand that you're trying to produce and
the experts need to weigh in on that and
and and then we can understand what the
what the parameters are to making sure
that that food is produced safely thank
you U representative Scully and then
representative uh wheeler and then Bixby
thank you madam chair so is it um legal
to make and sell freeze-dried ice cream
in New Hampshire currently under the
homestead um no just can anybody do it
we we would require them to be in a
commercial um facility yes okay so and
have a license may I follow yes sure a a
commercial facility can can do after
your inspection so it's a requirement
for inspection correct all right one
want to follow up please
so if um Can is it possible to inspect
Homestead operations or do they lose
their status if you come in and look at
those no we do we we license uh we do
license and inspect homesteads uh there
are categories of homesteads that are
exempt that are exempt from licensing
inspection but there are homesteads that
we do license and inspect may ask one
quite the quick question thank you um
how how honorous is the inspection is it
is there a great cost to the person
being inspected
um does I'm sorry thank you for the
question if I'm understanding correct
are you asking if there's a cost to the
producer for the inspection or for the
license yeah does what costs were
involved to the person who is trying to
provide that service or create that
product it's the for paid to us would be
the licensing
fee um representative kto wanted to add
to what you were saying uh thank you
madam chair representative um Scully I
believe that they're already licensed
under the Homestead Act already The Next
Step would be is the commercial kitchen
which is extremely expensive it's the
tens of thousands of dollars um so just
so you know there is the homestad food
act so where there's exemptions but no
inspection and then there's a next step
up if you want to sell in retail places
or whatever you have to be licensed and
that's where DHHS comes in but there are
certain foods that are Exempted under
that license am I saying that
correctly certain foods yes so non
potentially haard food correct correct
and then to do anything else it's a
commercial kitchen
license all right so thank you so I
guess we're trying to allow them to do
this without becoming a commercial
kitchen okay represent Bixby and then
wheeler or or was
it yeah so go ahead so if uh so
I'm I gather that there are both sort of
um hom grade and commercial grade
dehydrators if someone were to have a
freeze dryers freeze freeze not yeah
freeze dryers um so if someone were to
have a uh commercial grade freeze dryer
and use recipes that were that were uh
recommended by that freeze drying freeze
dryers
manufacturer uh
would uh would that would that be
safe I I guess I couldn't speak to that
I don't I don't know if they have
recipes standard recipes for so so um I
presumably if someone is in a commercial
kitchen running a
dehydrator then they are using uh would
they be using recipes that had G
undergone process review yes okay so if
someone were to uh do the same thing but
not in a commercial kitchen would what
they were doing be
safe so I don't know that we can fully
answer that I mean one thing that a
concern that comes to mind is whether
the um process has gone under review
including the space so I think you know
the in a commercial kitchen there are
certain standards that have to be met
and those standards wouldn't NE you know
beyond just the freeze dryer I think
we're talking about here freeze dryer
there's other there's other standards in
a commercial kitchen that protect you
know that serve for food protection as
well so I think I think we can't sit
here and say yes absolutely it would be
safe in that instance because there's
still some concerns about whether
there's potential for food uh food born
illness as a result of the process okay
um follow up follow up so with the level
of
um of uh thoroughness for inspection of
a commercial kitchen be higher than the
level of thoroughness for in of
inspection for a licensed Homestead food
operation it it's not it would not the
thoroughness I mean we're uh the
department takes food safety seriously
so you know we're th whether we're in a
homestead or a commercial space
however depending on the process and the
product and the license class there are
different standards that need to be met
okay so I guess what I'm wondering
is if someone had commercial if someone
on a with a homestead license had a
commercial freeze dryer would that be a
viable possibility or would that just be
outside the realm of what you would
consider safe so it's not just about the
equipment it really is about the product
and the process and the evaluation of
the product um and then um and then the
inspection to to ensure that they're
Meeting those safety parameters okay
thank you okay um down on this side who
who wanted to go oh representative
wheeler go ahead and then thank you
madam chair can you tell us a little bit
more about the process that DHHS uses to
determine whether or not they support or
oppose or are neutral on a piece of
legislation so the department would
evaluate the um St you know the the
concerns I can speak to in terms of
Public Health so we look at the public
health risk and if we have concerns we
would you know certainly bring those
forward those are discussed internally
at the department and we determine
whether or not we would uh have a formal
position as I said earlier we're neutral
but we wanted to make sure we brought
forward the concerns that we have
relative um to freeze drying follow up
followup this has been alluded to by
representative Miner and representative
Aaron but uh in the case study you
brought forward to us was uh one case of
this happening in 11 years or something
along those lines wouldn't that indicate
to you that this in fact is a safe
procedure and people uh only one
instance have somebody doing this in an
unsafe way in the last 11 years seems to
me you know accidents do happen we're
not going to have zero of these cases so
one in 11 years seems to me like this is
working out pretty well and I I guess
the I have a disconnect between the
concern and the prevalence that I'm
seeing of the accidents that happen in
this case you Rectify
that I so this you know expanding the
visions that are currently allowed for
right now do not include uh potentially
hazardous foods and so that is a better
practice best practice so by expanding
that the the the the department has
concerns about the way this legislation
is written about expanding that to
include non poent I'm sorry potentially
hazardous foods that could introduce a
greater risk moving forward if this
legislation were enacted because it
could could create concerns about
addition food born
illness and I I can just follow up on
that um as as Michelle noted it's not
currently allowed so this is not a um a
current practice that
happens generally with food I would
follow up but then it would be
cross-examination and so I won't do that
all right um we have we have we're
really running late so I'm going to have
uh representative Penza and then H
Haskins and hopefully we can go on to
the next person to
testify um thank you madam chair sorry I
came in late so I just have a couple
questions because I'm reading over the
bill I've got freeze-dried ice cream in
front of me I'm quite confused so let me
just um and I ate some of it under the
table and uh please don't arrest me all
right so um I want to understand um so I
see right here if this is the you know
the dark line food that is free dried
freeze-dried shall not be considered
potentially hazardous food but that
means that obviously if they have a
homestead food license they are not
making ice cream so it would have to be
and someone mentioned this earlier I'm
just this is a clarifying question that
they would be buying let's say you know
organic ice cream or something like that
taking that into their Homestead in
freeze drying it or whatever else that
could be considered potentially
hazardous correct
it correct that it would allow them to
take potentially hazardous products but
they're not making the potentially
hazardous product they like they're not
making ice cream or you know they're not
um slicing up pig or anything like that
they're literally grabbing that already
which is okay so I just wanted to make
that clear so your your only concern is
in the your concern is in the processing
part of that is your concern in them
Gathering stuff that has already been
made and licensed in a commercial
kitchen you don't have any problem with
that
correct thank you for the question so it
it's not necessarily about that it's
been made in a commercial kitchen it's
about the initial state of the product
so ice cream is considered um
potentially hazardous it needs requires
refrigeration for safety so when you
take a a product that requires ref
Refrigeration for safety whether it's
commercially prepared or not and you
turn it into a non-p potentially
hazardous product that process is is the
concern
okay okay clear represent H
Haskins chair and thank you for taking
my question like everyone on this
committee I would desperately like to
understand where we're stuck um so the
process of making
candy is allowed under a homestead
license correct why because it's a non-p
potentially hazardous product it's not
something that requires refrigeration
from safe for safety and we're not
concerned about the risk of food born
illness these are lowrisk products that
are basically shelf stable so if you're
taking a a lowrisk shelf stable product
and you're freeze drying it there
there's no concern there however if
you're taking a potentially hazardous
product that requires refrigeration for
safety and you're turning it into a
product that can be stored on the Shelf
we want to make sure that that process
that that takes it from non I'm sorry
from potentially hazardous to non-p
potentially hazardous to make sure that
it's achieved the proper water
activity to be safe on the shelf and
quick followup so I mean I I take a risk
every time I determine whether I cut the
chicken with that knife and I'm now
going to do the apple is the cutting
board you know I mean in food prep and
when I eat at a restaurant I take my
chances right so um I thought at first
that we could exempt certain foods that
that would be helpful CU these folks
don't want to do turkey and all the rest
but you're now talking about process
right couldn't they go Ary in the
process of freeze drying their
candy because it's an already an
inherently safe product to Candy there's
there's there's there's not really risk
for foodborn illness in candy so you're
taking a a safe product and you're just
changing the you're freeze drying it to
make it a a different texture or um it's
crunchier or bigger or you know whereas
you're T if you're taking a a a product
that's refrigerated for safety a
potentially hazardous product and you're
making it non-p potentially hazardous
there it's again it's that process of
making it safe that is our concern thank
you okay thank you any other questions
from the
committee okay thank you thank you um
I'd like to call Chris
Norton to uh
testify and I don't have any other pink
cards after that so
uh just let you know we're running late
here uh good afternoon uh Madam chair
and members of the committee
um so I I know we're a bit late so I'll
do my I'll do my best to keep it concise
uh I'm here basically uh to uh testify
in support of uh Bill 505 um and I want
to give you a perspective of somebody
who attempted to start their own small
scale uh freeze-dried produce business
last year uh so uh as I as I kind of uh
go over this please keep in mind that my
goal was to ultimately sell at a farmers
market in Milford um and what this
really boiled down to was in the spring
of Summer of last year uh I started uh I
basically started
um working on creating a kind of a
smallscale uh uh uh freeze-dried produce
business where I would Source everything
from local farmers so during the spring
and summer I used that time to establish
relationships with uh some local farmers
in our area uh I would buy bulk produce
from them and then bring that home and
process it to kind of work out my
procedures my processing um as I started
to realize that I had what to me seemed
like a viable business model what I
decided to do was then reach out to the
Department of Health and Human Services
because as their website States this is
not something that's covered under
current Homestead guidance uh so I had a
incredibly good conversation with uh a
woman named royan BOS uh who was just
incredibly helpful in laying out
everything I had to had to accomplish
including creating um creating a hazard
analysis plan um sending any any items
that I produced off to Cornell to be
tested for active water um and through
all of that while it did seem like a lot
again I am a fan of a good process I'm a
I just really enjoy testing so I took
that I took that went away and started
um basically working on basically
working on my own procedures within
those guidelines uh and I want to make
sure right and also as part of that um I
worked with the manager of the Milford
Farmers Market who was able to find me a
commissary kitchen that I could work out
of the major downside to doing that
house ever would be in order for me to
operate under current guidance I would
need to take all of my equipment
including our freeze dryer move it into
a commissary kitchen uh and that's where
it would kind of reside and then uh
something that hasn't been mentioned but
the the length of time that these
processes take uh is quite significant
um the machine that we have at the
moment in certain instances can
take uh 24 to 48 hours to do an entire
batch of produce
so um I it's something that you know I
could leave it up and running but these
machines have issues sometimes I would
have to constantly be going back and
forth from our house to a to the
commissary um and then from a monetary
standpoint what I was essentially
looking at uh again to sell these things
at a farmers's market uh I was looking
at a licensing fee of around $350 to be
considered a food processing plant uh
the items that I wanted to sell uh
initially were uh apple chips
raspberries blueberries and cherries uh
I'm forgetting one but uh with with the
setup and the fees associated with the
testing that was around another $600
that I was looking at in terms of just
testing uh any changes to my recipes or
my processes would necessitate another
round of testing so that would be an
additional cost um my wife likes to use
an example of well what if I want wanted
to use a different ratio of cinnamon on
one of the things I would just look at
her and say yep that means we're going
to have to send it back into testing and
you know it's kind of a joke in our
household um but overall uh what ended
up happening was with all of this with
all the procedures and all the guidance
uh I was doing my best to kind of Chunk
through it on my own um and what
ultimately made me stop was or put it on
pause I should say is um when I had
created what I thought was a appropriate
Hazard analysis plan I did send it back
to Department of Health and Human
Services and just to get some feedback
and uh it was the feedback was great the
only thing was is I effectively had
created an outline um so what I needed
to do was go back and create additional
flowcharts to kind of show you know the
potential things I could run into how I
would mitigate them things like that um
and then in addition uh I found out a
about a more efficient
machine uh that would have that would
have made my life a little bit easier
would have increased increased my
productivity uh however because it would
be a new machine there would be The
Upfront cost of that and then I quickly
realized that I would also have to go
back and I would have to redo all of the
uh the processes and procedures that I
had done based on the old machine so
it's I am in no ways sitting here
telling you that I am defeated or I'm
not going to continue along these lines
but um it's just something that I had to
stop and say okay let's re-evaluate you
know how do I actually do this
realistically as an individual um so
that's why I am here in support of this
bill uh largely because uh for me
personally starting my own business is a
dream of mine and this would be a good
way for me to at least prove it as a
proof of concept um if I were to go go
to a larger scale where I intend to sell
at retail or across state lines that is
a whole host of other procedures that I
absolutely would abide by but for now as
somebody who basically wants to support
local farmers um support local farmers I
very much am big on reducing food waste
and also just looking for ways to give
back to my community this would be a
really good opportunity for me um the
one last thing to mention as far as
giving back
uh over the past you know over the past
year I've had uh a number of friends who
have been impacted by natural disasters
they've had their pantries ruined um and
I've been able to take a significant
amount of food put it in a relatively
small box um and send that off to
somebody you know send that off to
somebody who is in generally in need of
restocking their Pantry or um just need
something that you know is going to be a
little bit stable for a longer amount of
time so um my representative uh
representative uh Barber has submitted
uh a written testimony to all of you um
and I do apologize I've kind of been
jumping around uh but um I'm happy to
take any questions I do understand that
we're running late y thank you thank you
I appreciate uh I appreciate your
testimony um we have questions from the
committee representative barar thank you
madam chair thank you Chris for coming
uh before us today um I have a a
question about the
process sure processes that you
um worked on in order to develop your
recipes did you make those up or did you
find that um there was a resource for
you to actually get those processes and
did was it
determin did they deter did the type of
fruit matter which process you used so I
it's a mix uh so what I did was because
I had because I had contacted Health and
Human Services I had a rough framework
of what I should be operating under in
terms of food safety handling things of
that nature um in terms of the
actual developing the actual processes
um I can tell you that my process for
making apple chips is completely
different than the way I handle peaches
it is also completely different than the
way I handle cherries um all of those
take different amounts of time
uh in in the same machine so I know in
the case of something like uh in the
case of something like a cherry I know
that I have to pit it and after I pit it
I know that I have to slice it so that I
have enough surface area exposed that I
can lay them all out nicely and then put
them in the freeze dryer and then
increase the amount of time to a certain
amount and then I can be fairly sure
because it hasn't been tested I can be
fairly certain that those are um
sufficiently freeze-dried but um again
that would be what I would have needed
to send them off for testing for
followup
so um I guess maybe I didn't ask my
question correctly Sor is this
information on how how you process the
fruit Y how long you dehydrate what the
um the um moisture content is is that
something you created or did you have
guidance
and where can someone find that guidance
for that so typically typically if we if
you're looking for a more official type
of guidance there is a user manual that
typically comes with all machines it
does give you recommended settings for
certain types of things that is usually
or in my case that's what we use as a
starting point and then the the devils
in the details when you start you know
expanding on that um for what it's worth
there are online communities that you
know to share knowledge but um you know
that is something that everyone's
experience is going to be different but
you can use those as a type of
resource any other questions from the
committee no seeing none thank you very
much for your time um for all the folks
who have come in uh and I guess you're
looking to uh uh for the hearing for HB
396 we are I just want to let you know
we are running about a half hour
late uh after we close out this hearing
uh we have one more another hearing
before uh HB 396 so I just want
everybody to kind of know where we are
in the in the scheme of things here uh
are there any other pink cards anyone
else who wishes to speak on HB
505 seeing none I'd like the blue sheet
please for uh HB
505 and uh on the online portal we had
nine people in support zero people in
opposition and zero people neutral on
the uh on this
Bill thank you representative Miner and
we had one person in favor on the blue
sheet with that I am going to close out
the hearing on h505
and uh the next bill is HB
642 which I am the prime sponsor so I'm
going to be up there
and I will have
represent no worries and then I uh I'll
have representative ktoa be uh in in um
control of the meeting then no you did
great thank you did you get my
email okay I Haven received think it's
this
yes okay I have to read my
email okay been there done
that we've all made those newbie
mistakes not a mistake we keep repeating
it right
good afternoon I'd like to open the
hearing for HB 642 allowing the sale of
dehydrated meat without a homestead food
license uh Madam chair or representative
Aaron uh would you please fill out a
pink card when you have a moment not
after thank you yes I I shall do that
got a kick out of
that for the record my name is
representative Aron Representatives
representing Sullivan County District 4
the towns of aqu Goan Langan lemster and
Washington and in the same vein as we
have discussed
for freeze-dried
food I'm bringing forth this uh Bill
allowing the sale of dehydrated meat
without a homestead food
license
and I'm here today to introduce this
bill I filed this bill in response to a
constituent who raises beef and who
would like to sell dehydrated meat that
he already makes for his family and
friends none of his family or friends
have ever gotten ill from consuming his
beef
jerky the process of drying meat takes a
potentially hazardous food and makes it
into a shelf stable product according to
USDA publication which I have um passed
along to
everybody um dehydrated meat or as we
commonly know it as jerky is a food
known since at least ancient Egypt
humans made jerky from animal meat that
was too big to eat all at once such as
bear Buffalo or whales North American
Indians mix ground dried meat with dried
fruit to or Sue it to make pimkin
bong is dried meat or game used in many
African
countries how can drying meat make it
safe drying is the world's oldest and
most common method of food preservation
canning technology is less than 200
years old and freezing only became
practical during this century when
electricity became more available to
people drying technology is both simple
and readily available to most of the
world's
culture the scientific principle of
preserving preserving food by drying is
that by removing moisture enzymes cannot
efficiently contact or react with the
food whether these enzymes are bacterial
fungal or naturally occurring autolytic
enzymes from raw food preventing this
enzymatic action preserves the food from
biological action in the interest of
providing more WS for New Hampshire
Farmers to offer more diverse food
products to New Hampshire consumers I
think this bill would be a welcome
addition to what can be sold at Farm
stands and farmers markets and it isn't
necessary for producers to have
commercial kitchens or licenser to
produce this
product I've produced this product in my
in my home with my own dehydrator
machines the bill sets standards for
production and those standards can be
reinforced by information provided on
the Health and Human Service website
just as other guidelines are provided to
producers thereby minimizing risk or
foodborn illness we could require people
who produce these foods to take a class
on food safety it if that is the will of
the committee
in drafting this bill I know that there
were some errors that need some fixing
and I'm prepared to draft any amendment
to make those
adjustments one of which was on line
five on page one which talks about um
USDA USDA inspected meat that has been
freeze-dried without a homestead food
license um it should not be freeze-dried
it should be um just un USDA inspected
meat um um originally when I drafted
this bill I made this bill to be
allowing dehydrated meat as well as
freeze-dried products and because
representative shamberg had a bill
coming in to OS with freeze-dried
products mentioned OS contacted me and
said uh we're we're not going to put
your bill in and I said well then just
strip out the freeze drying part and let
his be an independent Bill and have mine
and so that's kind of where we are but
apparently the drafter didn't take out
the freeze-dried part so we would have
to amend the bill to fix that um the
other thing was that my intention was to
limit the amount of meat processed and
sold within a time period which was left
out of this bill draft too I had
originally wanted to add that people
can't sell more than 10 pounds of
post-processed weight of their product
in a week
and may not produce more than three
pounds of post produ processed meat in a
in a day so I I put some limitations in
there just because I felt that you know
we don't want to have people be you know
these hu a homestead become this huge
business um a commercial you know big
commercial kind of entity I wanted to
kind of keep it small and also by
keeping it small it's more
controllable there's a little bit more
um risk management that you can you can
wrap your hands around so that's the
intention of this particular um Bill uh
I mentioned in it um you know the
process by which uh a person would be
able to uh produce dehydrated meat I've
taken that right from the
USDA uh
website um what they recommend um that
you know how how the meat has to be
refrigerated to a certain degrees uh
meat would have to be steamed or roasted
to certain degrees before it is
dehydrated in order to kill any kind of
um you know bacteria or or
organisms and
um and that's basically it so um I'd be
happy to entertain questions um I don't
believe that my constituent is here who
actually does this but I ran this bill
by him and he says yeah this is what I
do and
um you know I've been able to make it
very safe and I'd be happy to abide by
these rules if they are made uh into law
so thank you representative Jama J thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
get to call you representative when
you're sitting over there uh I've been
demoted
right only temporarily uh so if I have a
question then if I'm permitted to follow
up just for
clarification uh uh at line nine page
one line9 the the meat is refrigerated
at 40 fah or slightly below I'm a
little confused by what slightly means
I'm wondering what the temperature range
it's just a clarification question yeah
sure well you know I just grabbed the
the language verbatim from the USDA
website so I mean you know if if we want
to be a little bit more precise or
strike that entirely or put a range of
of uh degrees uh I'd be happy to
especially since I know we're going to
have to if we want to proceed with this
um do some kind of amendments to the to
the bill anyway because there's issues
with it may I have followup followup
thank you and I appreciate that because
I was wondering if it might be a range
because I literally don't know if
slightly in this case is a degree or
three right right right but so I
appreciate that y uh and then just for
my clarification at line four meet is is
marinated only in the refrigerator I
take that to mean that it is stored in a
Refrigerated unit while it is marinating
as opposed to being left out marinating
at room temperature yes okay thank you
very much that's the safe procedure
protocol which is recommended y I
thought just wanted the clarification
thank
you represent King thank you madam chair
um I have a question that's a little bit
more philosophical I I hope I hope I can
ask this it's appropriate
but we're getting a lot of bills similar
to this vein
and it's like for for a long time the
food production industry has been
heavily corporatized
centralized and these types of bills are
really helping to decentralize that um
democratize it if you will and I feel
like with it being
centralized um you know you're getting
most of the time you're getting a
standard product things seem to be safe
but it really it really prevents the
little guy from competing in that market
unless they already have Deep Pockets
and if we have bills like these come
about it seems like it definitely gives
the little guy a chance but do we do we
lose something do you do we lose is
there is there is there a risk that we
previously didn't have that we would be
having if we
started allowing the little guy who
maybe doesn't have as Deepa pocts uh
pockets for lawsuits or whatever what do
you think the downside is of
letting the little guy get a a foot in
the door in in this regard I actually
don't think there is a downside I mean
we saw uh during covid uh empty shelves
in the supermarket where the
corporations were the ones that could
not provide food for us and and we had a
lot of people who were seeking Foods
locally from our local farmers and I I I
think we sort of got this um Epiphany
that we have people who are absolutely
capable in our local communities to
producing these things and um producing
them even in in a very ethical and very
um Common Sense way and carefully and
mindfully because they live in these
communities they deal with the the their
neighbors their friends um I
think I think by
um creating more opportunity for our
Farmers is nothing but a win situation
for everybody because there's more food
in our system being
produced um and there's more opportunity
for smaller entrepreneurs to offer
diverse product to uh to offer more
things to more people
people um and then you know to
representative Miner's point before in
earlier testimony I mean we see these
big corporations uh who are under great
scrutiny and you know being inspected
all the time there's recalls every day
for you know Bor head baloney or
whatever Smithfield's ribs or whatever
and peanut butter anything um because
they're
not they're they're contaminated or
tainted in one way or another or
perceived as being tainted or whatever
and I think you know there's a lot to be
said for um a little bit more local
control and
local um involvement in the food that
we're
consuming thank you representative for
being here and bringing this bill forth
would you say that New Hampshire has a
large cottage industry
I would say we do and I'd like to
encourage further growth of that okay
and and because it's such a uh huge
cottage industry State
um the foot people finding out about bad
products is pretty quick and uh tracking
something where someone got sick is
probably a lot quicker than uh a large
National Corporation uh that
disseminates tens of thousands of pounds
of product at a time um would you say
that being able to trace a product in
New Hampshire or someone getting sick uh
you would know exactly where it's uh
coming from rather quickly and it could
be eliminated um and if there was a bad
actor would that spread quickly so that
no one would then purchase from that
person yes and I think we've seen that
with our raw milk
legislation um so yeah I mean I I think
that uh you certainly Word of Mouth gets
around pretty quick if you have somebody
who's producing something that's subpar
they're not going to be in business very
long um I you know and I also made
provision in this bill uh for labeling
you know that that um you know you have
to have certain information on your
product label um and the there would
have to be signage where where the point
of sale is uh regarding the name of the
meat producers business
the email address the phone number the
name of the product and a statement to
say that dehydrated meat and meat
products from this meat producer
distributor are made with USDA inspected
meat and are exempt from New Hampshire
licensing and inspection so there is an
element of allowing and letting the
customer know where this is coming from
who's produced it where it's been
produced and because they're buying it
from their producer they can ask
questions about the process they're
actually right there with the people who
are making the product and being able to
say what is in this how did you make it
so they can feel better or or more
secure you you don't get to ask those
questions when you know you're buying a
package of Hillshire Farm bacon or
whatever so uh I I I don't know I I just
think um you know even as we are
promoting eat local support our local
farms this bill and some of the other
food bills that we've been uh dealing
with absolutely do do
that any other questions from the
committee represent
Penza thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um just a did
this bill comment is do you feel that
this bill is like timely for everything
that's kind of going on um you know on
the federal government side in our
country right now how we're trying to
turn back to the local and small farmers
because it seems as if um corporate
Farmers have have taken over and it's
been going on for a long time so we're
definitely behind the eightball um do
you think that this could help one New
Hampshire is my first question and um do
you believe that there's like further
things that we could do in New Hampshire
outside of um you know outside of this
bill to be able to promote that that
that local you know local Homestead food
producing um that seems as if our new uh
Secretary of HHS is is pushing towards
as well um on the federal
level well I don't know about the
federal level but I certainly do think
that you know this is this is a big uh
Boon this would be a big Boon to our uh
agricultural community in New Hampshire
would help our local farmers it would
help them become more diverse in the
products that they're able to to offer
to their local
customers and um I I just think that you
know overall yeah uh and people do want
to get back to I don't want to say you
know the old ways of doing things but
you know in the olden days yeah you went
to your local Farmer for whatever cuts
of meat or bacon or smoked smoked items
um any any produce that they that they
grew and you knew where where your food
was being uh raised and you knew how it
was being raised uh and I think that
people really want to have that again um
I mean I'm all for big corporate
business and God bless them let them let
them make whatever money and and produce
their products but I think there's
there's
also a part of us that wants to be close
to where we live and and be comfortable
with what our local farmers are doing
and support them and uh this is another
way in which we can do that with
especially with the food bills that
we've been
considering seeing no other questions
thank you very much I'd like to call
Erica Davis and Michelle robers from the
Department of Health and Human Services
good afternoon for the record my name is
Michelle robers I'm the bureau chief for
public health protection within the
Department of Health and Human Service
services and with me this afternoon is
Erica Davis and she's the food
protection section administrator with
the Department of Health and Human
Services and she's going to provide the
testimony for us today good
afternoon so House Bill 642 would create
an exemption under our a 143 A5 to allow
for dehydrated meat to be uh produced
without a homestead license this
testimony is going to be very similar to
the free stride um food testimony as the
processes are
similar so we currently do not allow for
dehydrated Meats to be preserved in a
homestead food operation the only
products that may be produced in a
licensed or exempt Homestead food
operation would be non potentially
hazardous food products dehydration is a
specialized process whereby the water
activity is reduced in a product to
prevent harmful growth of
microorganisms this process should be
done in a commercial facility with
commercial equipment and have a process
Authority evaluate the product and the
process um prior to
sale for this bill without the ability
to license or inspect there would be no
oversight
uh to ensure that meats are you are from
a USDA inspected Source there's no way
there would be no way for us to
ascertain how many facilities may be
conducting this process and without with
this lack of oversight it could hinder
the Department's ability to conduct the
necessary foodborn illness outbreak
investigation should there be one and
potentially restri restrict our ability
to trace back products to the source
again I'd like to point to the 2013
outbreak for chicken jerky pet treats
which resulted in U 43
illnesses and I can take any
questions should you have
them any questions represent Bixby so um
would you be more uh comfortable with
his bill if it were using a licensed
Homestead
kitchen thank you for the question um it
still is it still is a commercially I
mean excuse me it still is a potentially
hazardous product that's
being through the process of dehydration
turned into a non-p potentially
hazardous product so it is a specialized
process of a meat product which we would
not allow in a homestead kitchen
and uh so um would you
um uh one of the things that we did when
when we uh started allowing the sale of
um uh poultry and rabbits to restaurants
was we set up a course uh at um through
uh Co-op extension to give people the
training to do that would you be for
more comfortable with this ex W with
this exception to the potentially
hazardous uh food product uh restriction
if if there were uh uh a course um that
people someone could go through in order
to become uh qualified to do
this thank you
I I think that any educational
requirement is a help um to producers um
who are taking on a specialized process
however it does
not help with the specific product
itself so when we ask for a dehydrated
meat product to go through a process
evaluation to ensure that the farmer
specific process and marinades and um
dehydration of the product meets those
standards the education may not Point
directly to their process okay thank
you if I may add please um because a
process review allows for the experts in
that particular area to weigh in in
terms of how to to do it safely and
properly the process that's really a a
concern so the education is is good but
it doesn't um uh take the place of a
process review representative
Penza um thank you madam chair thank you
for my question so I don't know if you
have the bill in front of you but um
like right in the beginning on line four
um wouldn't it put the agencies mind at
ease because it right there at the
beginning says a meat producer
distributor who has licensed to sell
USDA inspected meat may sell USDA
inspected meat that has been
freeze-dried wouldn't that right there
because of we know um what you have to
go through in regards with
that be enough thank you for the
question so the USDA inspected meat is
meat that's been SL watered and
packaged in a USDA facility so that raw
product that comes with the stamp from
USDA but then there this in this bill
they would be taking that product and
dehydrating it to make another product
so you're taking it a potentially
hazardous meat product and turning it
into a non-p potentially hazardous shelf
stable
product represent Jama
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so if I recall
correctly there was one of the concerns
you expressed was about if there's an
outbreak tracking outbreaks and and so
I'm looking at the labeling requirements
here it's a it's a freeze stried package
that contains information about the
producer and the
distributor wouldn't that help the
department pretty thoroughly track down
potentially tainted products the
labeling requirements in the Bill thank
you for the question
it would if they're adhering to those
standards and without licensing or
inspection we have no way to evaluate
the labeling so we would if the labeling
is improper or incomplete it can lead to
difficulty tracing back uh product I
have followup follow up thank you so and
I'm not familiar with how the process of
investigating these concerns work so but
what I I would imagine is if somebody
there's there's an outbreak there's an
illness it's report reped you
investigate it you find you know
packaging um are you able to then you
know test the product and be able to
determine at that point if it was not
dehydrated or or packaged
correctly if it's deter
if if we have a foodborn illness
outbreak and there is a common product
associated with the illness we can test
the product to um link it back to the
illnesses and if all the pieces fall
into place
properly we can track it back and this
the illness um outbreak that we
presented You is kind of the The Perfect
Storm we were able to um
identify uh the ill individuals the
product where it came from link it back
and Link the illness um
the the product to the ill individuals
so it was kind of a full circle outbreak
investigations which don't
always illness outbreaks don't always um
end in the the perfect wrap
up okay thank you for the
clarification any other questions seeing
none thank you very much I appreciate it
I represent Miner could I get the blue
sheet please
online there are seven in support and
three opposed and the blue
sheet zero so I will close the hearing
for House Bill
642 okay
here's
this
okay all right give me a second here to
switch here switch
gears okay yeah now
okay we've got a number of cards here
for HB 396 and I apologize again that uh
we were supposed to start at 2 o'clock
and here we are at uh 238 anyway let's
see if we can make up some
time I'm going to open up the hearing
good afternoon everybody thank you for
coming to environment and agriculture
committee this afternoon I'm going to
open up the hearing for HB 396
exempting meat and meat food products
slaughtered and prepared in state for
sale in state for from certain
inspections and I
uh am inviting our sponsor of this bill
representative Barbara
ktoa
to come and introduce the bill to uh
this committee thank you welcome to the
committee
thank you madam chair it's good to be
here thank you uh colleagues I
appreciate uh the opportunity to present
this bill um as many of you know this is
a bill that's near and dear to my heart
especially in the farming Community to
help small farmers and hobby
Farmers this bill has been brought about
and I understand that this bill will
need some
amending there'll need to be some
labeling requirements and there may need
to be some limits so I just want you to
keep in mind that uh I'm hoping that
this committee will work to make this
the best build possible to help all of
our
Farmers right now in New
Hampshire in order to sell a cut of meat
either from
beef
swine sheep or
goat you have to go through a USDA
process
facility and if you do go through that
USDA processing facility and you want to
say sell smoked bacon and you take it to
a Smokehouse that is not USDA inspected
you cannot sell that bacon as USDA and
cannot sell that to your
consumer so I just want everyone to be
aware of the nuances of the
law right now there's a year and a half
to two-year waiting list at all USDA
facilities in New Hampshire
okay I believe uh Conway just opened up
again we were down to three I believe
we're up to four
again these Farmers have to set dates
well in advance of even knowing when the
animal will be
born for
processing we we've heard I've been on
several study committees it's like well
you know the farmers don't know how to
plan out they have all their processing
done at one time that is not
true
farmers understand the business it is a
247 7-Day A Week business and it's hard
and we need to give them the opportunity
not only them but the consumer who
doesn't want to buy a half a cow or a
quarter of a cow they want to buy a
steak and why shouldn't they be able to
get that from their local farmer whom
they Trust
we've heard today about USDA
recalls I'm telling right now just in
January alone at one place it was a
177,000 lb sausage recall contaminated
with foreign
materials processed at a USDA
facility January 2025 105,000
PBS of frozen chicken
products because of misbranding and
Undeclared allerin at a USDA
facility I can go on there was one place
called Bruce Pac almost 10 million
pounds of
meat
recalled I don't think that New
Hampshire produces anywhere near
that the other thing is what people have
to understand is having raised animals
myself having had them both processed at
a USDA facility or at a custom Meat Shop
of my
choosing the safety the cleanliness at
the custom Meat
Shops I get to go in I get to decide if
that's where I wanted my meat processed
at a USDA facility you don't get to
decide where you want it done you have
to set that appointment a year and a
half to two years in
advance just
recently I had to call the USDA to do a
surprise inspection at a local USDA
facility because of things that should
not have been done I have photographs I
have not filed the Freedom of
Information Act yet but I
will this one farmer got back freezer
bured
meat brought it back to the USDA
facility they slapped another Farm's
label on top of that and so sold it to
that another Farm how did we catch that
from a
consumer a consumer was the one that
peeled back the label and wanted to know
what was going
on as we spoke about in previously we
are a small state we are a cottage
industry someone does something wrong
everybody knows about it if there's a
shop that's processed ing meat and it's
not good nobody will go
there but yet when it comes to
processing cuts of meat for the consumer
we don't have
choices it's one of four places that's
it if you want to sell a
cut I don't think that's right I think
as consumers we are smart enough to know
where we want to buy our local food I
don't think that you know for USA
facilities is sustainable to our feet
food
Movement we need more food processing
and more places to get local food in the
state of New Hampshire so that we become
more food
secure I'm happy to take questions okay
representative King thank you for that
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony today I don't know much about
this but I've heard complaints of um
family friends we have who raise beef
and and they say they really understand
beef and they know how to raise
different types of beef like for example
Kobe and stuff like that and um there's
been
murmurings that they believe um they've
had their meat um replaced by other
people's meat like you know they'll
they'll send in their meat and it comes
back and they're like this isn't Kobe
beef at all you know or like they feel
like their meat has been stolen from
them and given inferior meat do you
think that's a problem and how do you
even prove something like that or is
that just I don't know what do you have
to say about that so repes pres thank
you very much for the
question I have heard that on numerous
occasions not only have I heard that I
had one farmer go in and take a picture
of a meat
cooler where there was not enough air
flow in the cooler and they were
concerned about the the degradation of
their
meat so thank you yeah um representative
Bixby Penza and then
germana okay so um is the problem of um
having your H having the the wrong meat
returned to you strictly a problem with
the USDA plant or does that happen at
custom plants too that if that custom
plant is not
well-run thank you for the question
representative Bixby um I am going to
assume that that is very possible that
could happen at a custom plant but this
I do know for a fact um because it was
brought to my attention as I said I have
the
pictures so I can speak factually to
that
representative uh
Penza um thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question just as a
follow-up to representative King I've
actually heard that now three times
um we bought uh half of a cow or
whatever one uh one year and
um and these people they're experts they
know exactly from what they're feeding
their meat and how it looks and all of
that and um and so many of um many
places because they've had to be able to
do that they can they've had to um um in
a sense get multiple people to buy you
know what I mean because you to try to
get away from the S USDA piece or
whatever but um I was um appalled when I
heard that I haven't heard anything like
that from local farmers or local meat
producers that are still having to to do
that at all so I just kind of wanted you
to speak to that piece too where did
where have you heard that I've heard
that in um in my area up in straford
county and I've heard it um actually in
Coos uh thank you for the question so
I've heard it uh one from some Farmers I
mean let's face it if you have 300 you
know whatever how many you know beef are
hanging in the cool
you know and they're not labeled
correctly you could mislabel something
or you could say oh you're supposed to
get this much meat from this cow but
there's some mold or there's this on it
so now we're going to take it from the
next cow because there's acceptable
limit mounts um so yes uh do I believe
that is happening yes uh do I think that
it's all places no I I would never cast
everybody in that group um
because some people actually follow
everything to the letter and others
don't that's kind of like saying all
custom Meat Shops are meat processes are
great and all of them are bad it's never
that way it's you have the good and the
bad in
everything okay representative germana
and then Scully thank you madam chair
thank you representative for taking my
question I'm not nearly as knowledgeable
about the agricultural side of things as
a lot of my colleagues are um my my
sense is when we look at these kinds of
bills and we're talking about
exemptions one of the criteria that we
use is scale in terms of when it gets
above a certain scale this is where we
start to be concerned about inspections
so as I'm looking at this bill I'm
hoping you can help me understand I see
the the distribution to household
consumers within the state you can go
buy something directly from the producer
what I'm wondering about I'm hoping you
can speak to is number two restaurants
hotels boarding houses grocery stores or
other establ L Ms are at that point are
we talking about a scale where we start
to be concerned about inspection because
if a hotel is buying it for their
restaurant and they may buy from two or
three different producers it strikes me
that there's a larger likelihood that
there if there is an outbreak it's going
to be more difficult to determine which
source it comes from and that's a
problem for tracing it so could you help
me understand especially that part of
the bill and if we get to a point where
scale is an issue so I appreciate the
question and as I said right off the bat
that I believe that this needed to be
amended and scale is part of that
Amendment so and I would let listen to
the people that are in favor of this
bill the Farmers on what they think is
reasonable uh in a year because I don't
this is not going to be card blanch uh
if you're going to be selling on a large
scale then you know this is not the bill
for you this is for the small tah harby
farmer thank you very much he U
representative Scully and then Bixby and
then grber thank you madam chair um are
there s more facilities available that
are State inspected and regulated that
that would be now open if we're able to
pass this legislation uh thank you for
the question we
do if we were to be in state inspect you
can either be USDA inspected or state or
you can have a state inspection program
but usually not both in the same state
and the cost to be a state inspected prr
program is pretty prohibitive and not
only that is the requirements would have
to be the same as the USDA or more
stringent so it doesn't make sense to do
that followup followup okay so I mean
there are good people doing this but
they're at this point they're they're
not being regulated by if this was
passed they wouldn't be regulated by
anybody uh you're just relying on their
their good practices and and people
knowing whether they're doing it right
or not well well thank thank you for
that so there are many places people
that are
selling Whole cows whole pigs half pigs
that are not going to a USDA facility
and selling selling the the product and
having the meat processed and there's no
issues we don't hear of any issues going
on the thing is is they just can't sell
a
cut thank you welcome Bixby yeah so um
it seems like the one of the issues here
is that there simply Aren't Enough
USDA uh licensed facilities in the State
uh which in one on one level doesn't
create the kind kind of competition that
would make it uh difficult for someone
who is if if there were like 30
facilities in the state then the one who
is doing things really badly would lose
out from comp from the competition and
that kind of pressure is not present
here so what are the impediments to
someone starting a USDA facility in the
State uh thank you very much for the
question well uh representative Bixby a
lot of the people uh that have chosen
not to go the USDA route is one cash
flow obviously is
one the amount of paperwork and uh some
of these processes as we've heard in the
past have actually worked for USDA
facilities uh they understand the
regulations they understand what's going
on they have told us the
stories
and they feel that they don't have to
just have because you have a USDA
inspector on site doesn't mean you're
doing things right as I just
testified and I think that is the Crux
of the issue right just because
something is USDA doesn't mean you're
getting good
quality okay representative guber
and then
Panza right yes okay can I get it
right thank you madam chair and thank
you for testifying um I'm not familiar
with um meat processing very much but um
this seems like an encouraging idea to
get things into the right scale for New
Hampshire but my question is uh the term
custom Slaughter facility I don't know
if that's Define the statutes or safety
are there any health and safety
standards how does that um could you Ed
educate me good question and you know I
can't answer that question I would
actually have to look in to see if that
is defined in representative Bixby has
his hand raised so he may know the
answer yes custom Slaughter is defined
in statute um and it would be in the
same chapter that this would be
amending thank you okay represent
Penza um thank you madam chair thank you
for my question um just to kind of
follow up with what representative
Scully asked that's what I was talking
about with like you know purchasing a c
half a cow half a pig that those types
of things people are right now having to
scramble together because a lot of
people don't want necessarily full or
half or something like that um which it
doesn't make sense but they can't you
can't buy a cut meaning you can't go buy
a steak or all of that so my question to
you is at the farmers markets which
conquered has them um very popular there
are usually two to three different
trucks that are there that are selling
pork and different types of things and
they are selling Cuts so for those folks
are they having to go through that
entire process that you're talking about
so well thank you for the question so if
they're selling Cuts they would have to
be going to a USDA facility yes and the
thing to other to think about right is
we're only talking about intrastate
sales instate sales only this is not
going across state lines this is only in
state for New Hampshire anyone is in New
Hampshire okay representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so what is the
definition of a custom Meat Shop what
what am I to assume about a custom Meat
Shop uh representative Bixby is there a
definition of
that there is but I don't have it
memorized it's it's in the so thank you
for the question follow up if I may sure
you may would they be inspected or not
inspected so so that's one of the things
that we could discuss I mean you know
some facilities have a USDA inspection
but they're not a USDA facility so they
are USDA
inspected okay um so there's that I
don't know you know there's some other
caveats but I would urge this committee
to listen to the people
that are in favor of this and to read
some of the text of the people that are
in support of this there are a couple of
people that own processing facilities
that have contacted me but neither one
of them could be here one is in uh
Virginia and one of them I just couldn't
get away to get here so I would urge you
to go online and read those
testimonies and if you have questions I
am sure that they would be willing to
help with any
uh answer any questions thank
you okay representative
King thank you madam chair I was just
looking up some definitions online would
you consider the USDA meat processors a
cartel thank you for the question um I
don't know if I would consider them or I
don't think I can answer that
honestly okay any other questions from
the committee
you have no okay okay thank you for your
uh introducing the
bill um because I have a a number Fair
number of pink slips I'm going to uh
limit a testimony from everyone to three
minutes if you would not mind um and we
will have an opportunity to ask
questions after but I will be timing
everybody so I will let you know when
your 3 minutes are up um I call uh
commissioner Shan Jasper from the
Department of Agriculture to come and
speak good afternoon
commissioner good afternoon Madam
chairman members of the committee it's
going to be hard for me to uh respond
everything in three minutes I'm going to
go as fast as I can so first of all
there was a there was a comment made
about um corporate farms and I just
wanted to correct that 96 to 98% of the
farms in America owned by families 85 to
88 8% of the food produced in America is
produced on Family Farms so what is the
problem with the bill and can it be
fixed no it cannot there is nothing that
you can do to pass this bill and not be
in violation of federal law 1907 federal
government passed the uh the
original uh Bill the federal Meat
Inspection Act actually yeah was of 1906
but pass in 1907 in
1967 they amended that to include any
inate Commerce as well prior to 1967 you
could do exactly what is being proposed
here since 1967 you cannot legally do
that if you violate that law none of you
are going to pay uh face a penalty but
anyone who
participates in that
Commerce could
face uh being charged with a misdemeanor
and a $1,000 per event fine do you
really want to do
that um I would hope not because people
would think oh well the legislature has
done this and now we can go ahead and
move forward with it you
cannot um and I want to address a few
other things in there so the wait time
right now and by the way as far as I I
know the slaughter houses in New
Hampshire that are USDA inspected are
familyowned slaughter houses so you know
there may be one that isn't but as far
as I know the rest all are familyowned
there are wait times because there are
people who want to bring an animal in
once in a while everyone I know who has
a regular schedule has no problems and
this is one of the things I've talked to
the beef producers about is you need to
be feeding animals into the facilities
on a regular interval because what are
they supposed to do have their staff
sitting around waiting for something to
come in you have to be at capacity all
the time and so that's why there's a
problem um but in terms of the custom
custom is when you are doing it uh
you're bringing the animal to to
somebody to have
them do the uh Slaughter and and cutting
of that meat for your own use your
gasture family um but not for sale what
else does this bill do that nobody
talked about it also takes out the
requirements on the poultry end of it um
and that's a concern as well you can't
do it as I said but the effect of this
is right now you can do a thousand Birds
uh if you've raised them on your farm
20,000 on other conditions but um that's
coming away in the federal inspection if
I may there are also sanitary conditions
which you are removing because if you
look at the actual uh verbiage you're
taking out you're taking out all of that
as well glad to answer any questions
okay questions from the
committee representa Bixby and then
representative King so um I hadn't
thought about this question until this
morning when I was discussing this bill
with my wife and she said what happens
when the uh current federal government
uh gets rid of the
inspectors any thoughts about that well
I don't believe that that is going to
happen that's
theoretical uh of course but they would
have to address how that those
inspections would take place I mean who
knows I mean what happens if the
asteroid hits us I you know thank you
hey representative King thank you madam
chair uh you thank you for taking
questions you referenced federal law yes
um and this bill deals with intrastate
Commerce does the federal law also deal
with the intrastate Commerce as I said
in
1967 the uh Act was amended and so that
all inate okay um sales came under the
uh act okay I have a second question
second question um you mentioned
that if people were to do this they'd be
in violation of federal law um and I'm
just thinking of like for example you
know medical marijuana or other federal
laws that were really like nullified at
the state level and there were a lot of
people all around the country that were
willing to violate federal law and the
states kind of had a hands-off uh
approach and and we saw over time that
the feds took a hands-off approach too
in a lot of ways uh could you see that
happening with things like this where
maybe the feds would would be like eh
let's not bother them because you know
it's a States thing I I can't see that
when it comes to food safety what you
are doing you know in terms of medical
marijuana or just recreational different
I can tell you that there was a sheep
farm in Lee which they were saying oh
everybody owns this sheep and so they
had a thousand sheep say on the farm but
they were supposedly all uh individually
owned and then they were slaughtering
them there and essentially selling or it
was actually the point I think where
well you own half of this sheep and
somebody else owns the other half the
federal government came in and and shut
them down so that is a real case of
where that did
happen Okay represent
Penza um thank you madam chair um thank
you for taking my question can you
elaborate on that when was that that was
probably and I go by that place all the
time probably within the last 15 years
15 probably within the last
15 follow up follow up um I like
representative King's line of thinking
and do you see especially with um all of
the problems that have been happening uh
all across the country with um in
representative cona went through them
all um recalls and all of these things
um do you see that that is um changing
some especially with new new
Administration um and there is
definitely uh it looks as if there's
going to be a shift in in that for more
localized processing especially if they
are falling underneath what we call the
their their USDA certified and they've
been approved I I couldn't possibly
speculate on that and I'm not here to
defend the current system I'm here to
tell you that I don't believe you should
be putting people at risk under the
color of state law and in fact having
them risk being F and charged with a
misdemeanor what I'm what I'm going to
suggest is that you should be working
with a federal delegation to broaden
this this act such as it is for poultry
where you have on Farm you can do a
thousand but you've got to have courses
through UNH you have to find follow the
um sanitary code that the secretary of
agriculture has imposed and we pretty
much mimic that and uh and do that under
this bill there's no sanitary code
there's no
um uh no inspections of that and that
doesn't fix the bill because
underlying problem is it can't legally
be done and we have to fix this at the
federal L level do not put people at
risk maybe feel good but you're not the
ones who are going to face the
consequences of your
actions representative germana thank you
madam chair thank you commissioner So
based on you know your years of
experience uh is it is it safe to say
that it would be unwise for us to make
decisions based on what we think an
Administration a current Administration
may or may not do I think that would be
very unwise you are legislators you are
sworn to uphold the laws you're so and
that includes the constitution of of the
United States and the state of New
Hampshire and I think that you should be
doing that this is an emotional issue
and I ask you to take the emotion out of
your decision here and base this on the
laws that we are all sworn to uphold
that's why I didn't provide a fiscal
note because I I've told the uh LBA I
would not participate in anything that
was a violation of Law and me Prov
providing a fiscal note in my CA in my
opinion was a violation of of my oath
and I would not do it thank
you question uh representative
King thank you madam chair would you
believe there are a lot of federal laws
that are not also reciprocated at the
state level and just because we don't
have a state law in the books does not
mean we're violating federal law in some
cases that is true but this is very
specific and it is um you code 21
section 623 and if you have not read
read that please do you're also
repealing um us code uh 21 section
464c which has to do with uh with
poultry products in the requirements
there so please read those codes very
carefully and understand them as I have
I've studied the these codes for several
years now trying to g grip on what we
can and can't do I've also spoken with
person in charge of USDA for our region
and I'm familiar with what it takes for
someone to become uh licensed the
problem in my opinion from studying this
for years is the supply of animals if we
had enough animals going in on a daily
basis you would have more slaughter
houses can you cite those uh us codes
again you said us code 21 you yep uh us
code 21 section
623a or section uh 21 excuse me US code
21 section 464 c um and that is actually
the verbiage if you look at B that you
were removing from the current law
that's in the current
law okay so I have a I I guess I am
confused as to why it's okay for a
person to own a cow or a pig or whatever
or buy a half a cow or a half a pig and
have that slaughtered as opposed
to the custom Meat Shop having a having
a cow and cutting it up and selling it
individually because there is a this is
the the Live Free or Die State and you
know in the country this is allowed
everywhere because it is your animal and
you are personally understanding that
risk when you enter into Commerce the
person buying this does not have that
that same knowledge they are assuming
rightly or wrongly that the government
is going to at least try to protect them
and I would suggest as many recalls as
there are and I see them every day
because that's one of the bulletins I
get that we have far more Safe products
than we do uh unsafe products and so I
think that is uh that's an important
distinction um and we just you know we
can't assume that everybody that's going
to be slaughtering under uh under custom
and then selling it is going to be doing
it correctly again somebody doing this
as a custom is just as likely to be
unscrupulous or have unsanitary
conditions than somebody who is
inspected um but at least there somebody
there inspecting you are not having any
any traceability here in what we did
last uh session legislature did last
session I believe it was relative to the
non-amenable species including bison and
um essentially uh deer there is
traceability in all of that there is
packaging and that is not controlled the
feds decided not to do that because
certainly that wasn't as big a deal it's
becoming bigger and don't ever ask me to
try to explain why the federal
government does anything CU I will never
understand
that but I know what the law is and
rather I like it or not our job is to
uphold the laws and work to change them
uh as I said at the federal level we
should do that I think Farm Bureau
bureau's policy is going to be to try to
do that as well and I agree with that
and I think that we can do more but not
at the moment any questions
thank you commissioner thank you I'm
going to call Dan inis Senator Dan
inis and again I'll give you three
minutes and then we can ask questions
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee um I'm here briefly it'll
be less than three minutes I suspect um
and um Howard Pearl has signed in in
support Senator Pearl and um we've
talked about this this bill and I
appreciate the commissioner's comments I
understand where he's coming from and it
makes sense but I'm going to take a
different tack on this um I'm a
marketing professor at UNH um three
degrees in marketing and to me this is a
market access issue that's really what
this comes down to we have customers who
want great products from local farms
that they trust and understand and we
have farmers who need to get their
product to Market in an efficient and
effective way and get it to those very
customers that want it whether it's a
restaurant or an individual or a grocery
store and yet our government repeatedly
gets in the way of small farmers for the
record um and I should have mentioned
this Dan inis Bradford district 7 um I
have a small farm it's 150 acres
presently we have 25 head of wagu cattle
we're going to 50 we will be one of
those processors that the commissioner
mentioned who just sends the occasional
animal maybe one a month but that's not
going to be enough to get us the
preferential treatment we need to USDA
facility so we're forced to sell the
product in ways that are less effective
for us and cost more for us to get to
Market and that's not what consumers
want that's not what the small farms
want having a local processor in our
case a town or two over is much easier
to do it puts the animal under less
stress less cortisol other things
flowing through its system right before
Slaughter makes a better product for
everybody no producer be it a farmer or
a custom slaughterhouse wants to poison
or make a customer sick that's just not
what we're in the business of doing and
consumers are smart gee I bought that
beef from Dan and I threw up I'm not
going to him again right problem solved
um now that's I don't think that's going
to happen um you can get ill from food
that comes from all sorts of sources
even USDA inspected Chipotle famous for
the problems that they had you can get
eoli from be from Sprouts um there's
nothing that's without risk but I really
like this bill because I think it puts
everything right here right here with
the people we know and the people that
we work with and these custom slaughter
houses are small high probability the
owner is the one working with your
animal and they want your business they
want to keep your business they want to
help you to grow so they can grow so
this is a market access issue I hope we
can find a way to do it again I
appreciate the commissioner's comments I
understand what he's saying I'm sure
he's not wrong uh and yet the marijuana
comment I found intriguing um because it
may well be that the feds say you know
what we're just not going to look over
there I I can't say that that's the case
um but anything we can do to make it
easier for the few remaining small farms
in this state I think we should do and
you know I it's it's in my family it
skipped my father that was it I had a
moment of insanity and decided to do
this um I've learned a lot and it's not
easy to get to Market thank you okay
represent Penza thank you madam chair
thank you senator for taking my question
of course do you um do you think that
there is you know just kind of
piggybacking off of the commissioner's
testimony do you believe that there is a
way that we could craft this legislation
uh representative ktoa was was pretty
clear about this bill is going to need
to be amended y that we could still stay
within compliance of federal law and
make this happen it's an interesting
question you ask and and the
commissioner and I spoke a year or two
ago about
A system that the USDA does have in
place and it might be you know we could
work with them to find a way to make it
more accessible to the small farmers so
apparently and commissioner I don't know
if he's still here he's not um but the
USDA I had a similar Bill the USDA sent
us a letter sent it to him and said you
don't need this we have roving
inspectors that you can get to go to a
custom Meat House and be there as an
inspector that day it's not easy um I
don't think but that me may be a
direction we could go and maybe we could
tweak this a little bit you know in that
direction but I I don't know it's a it's
a tough one but but I was impressed that
that existed but but you've already
heard how hard it is to get a USDA
inspected facility to take your animals
we're going to have to pull an inspector
from one of those facilities to send it
to another one I think scheduling is
still going to be an issue represent
pend a followup yeah quick followup um
there's a there was a restaurant in
Massachusetts that um we used to go to
my husband's from Massachusetts that
sourced all of their meat local yes and
and I know that the they didn't follow
this process right so it was it was
great cuz like you could purchase um
like you were getting you know a prime
specifically from you know John Smith
farmer in you know um yeah uh fitur bass
or whatever it may be and it it was
really cool and it had all of their
stuff was sourced local and um I know
there's some other restaurants that do
that so is there a is there a carve out
already that is for some of these
restaurants that are doing Farm to Table
because I know it's happening because I
I I've seen it yeah I can't speak to
Massachusetts and how they do things so
I I have to say I don't know um I find
it intriguing though so
maybe I I wonder if some of those
restaurants are buying the animal and
taking it to a custom shop could be yeah
they're buying a half and then they're
processing it but you know that the
margins on a half are are a little bit
lower than they are on selling the
individual pieces so it's to the
farmers's benefit to get this thing
portioned off yeah representative King
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking questions you're just the person
I want to ask this I was thinking about
it I was thinking about it earlier but
seeing as how you have a background in
uh what Market uh options and things
like that yeah um it seems to me that
back in the old this is a little bit
philosophical but back in the olden days
brand name actually meant something
because that was like oh uh this is a
trusted brand and people you know knew
what they were getting and maybe they
paid a little bit of a premium for a
trusted brand but then maybe a small UPS
up startart um maybe had better value uh
but maybe not the same you know trusted
brand that you know Oscar Meyer or
Johnsonville Farms or something had can
you speak a little bit on that and and
and whether or not if we started
implementing these sorts of um uh
decentralized food food service bills if
that would um bring back the importance
of brand name again I think brand name
is fairly important um as a marketer of
course um and we're trying to build a
brand name um we're doing it very
locally we're selling eggs yes we've
raised our prices too um but uh the
brand is important but you know in the
national meat market you do have some
big brands that people recognize but you
know this bill is really about creating
small Regional Brands within our own
state so brands that the people of New
Hampshire Granite Staters know and love
and that's really what I think our small
farmers would be able to start to build
and we'd appear at some of those
restaurants a little more often um I'd
love to be at Joe faroh's place in
Portsmouth with our product and if
something like this can get through it
will facilitate that
process representative germana thank you
madam chair thank you senator for taking
my question so and I appreciate the fact
that the sponsor said that she was
willing to work with us in terms of
crafting an amendment particularly to
consider scale and and where we draw a
line between a smaller scale operation
and so I'm just
wondering with your experience in
marketing right I mean because to me
again I'm thinking about this bill if
I'm thinking about restaurants hotels
boarding houses Etc these seem to me to
be exactly the kinds of distribution
points that we intend to have yes
inspections for so where where in your
mind based on your uh academic expertise
and your expertise in husbandry uh does
that line fall I don't know um and I
could make something up but I won't um I
think they what kind of Professor are
you same kind of same professor as I am
a legis makes up stuff all the time
exactly it doesn't stop me there are
some folks behind me I know with the
Farm Bureau who might be able to shed a
little light on that um but I'm probably
not the guy I one more thing I point out
you know we sell raw milk in the state
right and that's what we buy and drink
um we get it from you know various small
farms around the state so we're already
doing some of this and nobody's getting
sick nobody's dying and the farmers and
the processors are taking care to make
sure everything is clean and good to go
and that will happen here follow up
follow up I'm sorry stepped in it with
raw milk because last year we had a
couple of bills I think our two years
ago on raw milk and and I just want to
point out that that we had a healthy
debate but we also drew a very specific
line in terms of scale uh and and we we
aired on the side of smaller scale with
raw milk yeah I appreciate that and and
I think this is a similar situation okay
representative Scully thank you madam
chair and thanks for taking my question
of course if I understood what you said
you had basically taken a run at this um
a while back actually had some
interaction with the interaction with
the federal government and they rendered
an opinion is that uh opinion can that
be made available to this uh committee
so we could evaluate it maybe the chair
could check with the commissioner I
think he probably still has that letter
I don't have my copy all right thank you
yes any other
questions quick question represent Penza
thank you madam chair um just a quick
followup maybe does it make sense to get
another opinion an updated one at this
point Point might new Administration new
things happening true true we're awfully
early in that new Administration so I
don't know but but I think that's not a
bad idea absolutely okay thank you okay
thank you Senator Andis call
Representative James
Summers three minutes three minutes
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee um after speaking with
um commissioner Jasper quite a bit on
and doing some research on it myself he
covered a lot of the areas that I was
going to mention so I'll keep it brief
and just go particularly to the what the
bill is written state state law
violations and federal law as what what
he did not cover or what expand on what
he didn't cover so um looking at the
actual bill the actual bill which
repeals 427 D um col 2-
a1b um and that's what this would do and
then change the wording of that actual
AR RSA what it does not do however is it
does not eliminate by doing that
repealing that it still would leave in
place RSA
A1C which actually states that provided
such that custom Slaughter does not
engage in the business of buying or
selling any carcasses part of carcasses
meat or meat food products and of any
livestock capable of use as human food
therefore you'd be negating exactly what
you're repealing just by leaving that
part in that's one thing now the second
part is is when you go retail when when
you look to go retail and that's the
second part part two of this that opens
up the whole can of worms in the state
that where we're looking at repealing
427 2A 1B however by going retail now
that opens up the obligations to meet
RSA 1461 1463 1465 1469
14611 1468 18
14621 and then again RSA 427 2a1 C all
these rsas go into labeling timeade
production in inspection all of this is
just State rules then earlier we were
talking about the marijuana um question
about what if we squeeze this by well
they actually with this section they
actually have a penalty section in 21
USC United States code 21 title 21
chapter 12 Subs section 661 which
actually goes into the penalization of
the state named for the governor of any
violations of food inspection delay and
of designation publication of Federal
Register notice of production of
alterated meat and meat food food
products designated by the state not
inspected so that's just that's just
from the 21 USC so they do have a
penalized section if we do not follow
the federal law and um keep keeping it
really quick um and you have copies of
your oh I have I have yes and all those
R essays we'd have to meet and so even
if we passed this we and it went to we
have a like I said the next very next
RSA in that section VI with counters
what's being repealed here and we would
have to meet all these other rsas and
have to do something with those to even
be able to appeal it and that's state
law okay thank you any questions
representative King thank you madam
chair thank you for taking questions um
you've definitely out L your opposition
to the bill it seems to me namely
because there's so many other Byzantine
laws on the books that we'd be in
violation of but aside from that do you
have any um any opinions on just the
intent of the bill I do understand the
intent of the bill and like I said I
actually agree with cinder in um inis is
that uh um a way of marketing I
understand Customs Slaughter and I know
earlier was the definition of what it is
it's basically that's the way I think a
lot of your home your home restaurant
stores go is that they actually buy the
whole cow take it to the place get it
slaughtered and then get it back that's
exactly what custom Slaughter goes here
we have I have one actually down the
street from me that does that exact
thing you take them maau they'll
Slaughter it for you and then and then
charge you a price to slaughter it and
give it back to you all the two sides of
beef you get plus what a however you
wanted um but as far as uh I do agree
with it that if there's a if there's a
certain way to get around this yes it
would I think it would take a at least
to get around all these different bill
um different rsas it would take a
heavily Amendment amended bill that
would um somehow you'd have to negate
the labeling requirements the time the
freezer time I mean the different
inspection qualities that always
required once you go retail there's a
lot of different stipulations in there
okay go ahead sorry represent Potenza
um thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so all of those rsas
that you um were talking about were all
based upon like if it was retail though
correct as soon as they sell it to a
store restaurant Hotel any of that
section two okay thank you very right
any other
questions seeing none thank you for
coming to testify today I call Sean
Bader good afternoon and welcome to
environment Agriculture and you have
three minutes good afternoon um I tell
us where you're your name and where
you're from I'm sea Bader I'm owner
operator of Bader Farm we are uh we
raise cattle uh swine
and poultry and we are also a custom cut
shop okay um I hear it all the time from
my customers I wish I could
sell a steak or a package of B bacon or
a package of sausage all the time
and this is a huge problem for us
because in the industry as a small
farmer you can't always find all the
people to buy an entire cow so you sell
three quarters of the cow and I get
stuck with the last quarter well you do
that two or three
times I got a lot of food in my freezer
do you know what I mean so it offers us
an opportunity to make a little bit more
money which allows us to expand our
business a little bit more it offers our
customers the opportunity to you know
our Slaughter customers the opportunity
to be more flexible with their product
and do a little better on their end as
well being able to sell by the cut which
helps them offset their costs and grow
their operation farming is a really hard
operation to grow if you can't retail
product it costs you know you're giving
deals to everybody for a large quantity
and those large quantities don't always
repeat you know what I mean
so if I sell half a cow to somebody and
it's a particular like an elderly couple
husband and wife they don't eat a lot of
food that cow will last them two years
that half a cow so that's not steady
business for us and it doesn't
necessarily make sense for them right so
for them they're looking
to come in buy a couple of stakes for
this week
come in buy a couple of chicken breasts
this week you know or whatever it is do
their grocery shopping from somebody
local that they trust a product that
they've created I mean let's be
honest this bill is just is in in my
opinion it's intended to basically do
the same exemption that poultry has
right
now poultry can be sold to restaurants
and and hotels it can be sold at local
markets not Market Basket cuz Market
basket's a distribution center so they
go interestate interstate not
interestate so that would eliminate the
big stores the Walmarts the market
baskets the victories or Haniford or
what stop and shops they would be
eliminated from that that option so
that's not really the concern that we're
looking at this is multiple levels of
customer direct basically so if I am a
custom cut shop and I cut for Betty Lou
Betty Lou sells to John Smith John Smith
is the End customer
you do you see what I'm saying if I sell
it to the hotel down the street the bed
and breakfast down the street and they
produce it for their customers their
customers
the the end of the line it's not going
into a retail chain it is going customer
direct either from our custom slaughter
house or from our customer's porch or
whatever it might
be does that make sense yeah so I I
don't see the purpose of making such a
big stink over Beef Pork and and Lambs
when we do all of this stuff with
chicken right now and chicken is way
more difficult to keep
safe than beef pork or Lambs okay thank
you time's up representative Bixby yes
so um representative inis mentioned uh a
possibility that he'd heard of uh that
he'd um heard from uh commissioner
Jasper uh and he didn't have the details
but something about um roping USDA
inspectors who would be able to uh do uh
part-time inspection part-time
inspection of uh at custom meat houses
wouldn't change the basic custom
operation but it would allow you to do
to have USD da inspected meet uh I would
still have to go through all of the
basis of becoming a USDA inspected
facility I would only
employ them part-time so they would
still need the infrastructure we would
still need the hasset plans we would
still need all of the safety measures
and and things put into place which are
very costly to come up with I've looked
into it and not only that I'm a small
operation so there's a lot of days we
run over eight
hours after eight hours if I'm an
inspected facility I now have to pay
$365 an hour for that inspector to be
present
how does that become cost effective for
me right do you know what I mean okay
that that's it's a hardship yeah that
that's a that's a very important
clarification thank you and
honestly this isn't like 1967 where if I
did something wrong it takes two years
for everybody to find out about it
unless it's front page news on the
newspaper it'll be on Facebook tomorrow
and 10,000 people will hear
it okay represent
Penza uh than thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question um I
want to
understand when you said okay so
someone's let's say they buy half a cow
and you know you're you can buy as small
as a quarter cow a quarter okay so well
let's just say a half and then you still
you're left with a quarter and then
you're having to freeze that first
question that has to be for my
consumption correct how um how long does
that last un unless you have like a a
deep freeze process like how long is
that meat good
for um vacuum sealed 2 to 3 years really
as long as the packaging doesn't get
damaged wow okay followup oh I didn't
realize that okay so let's say I have
like there's this I don't even know what
it's called it's this like little shop
that sells all local products it's in
hooks it it's right off of the exit um
they have like local PL pies all that
kind of stuff if they bought half a half
a cow or something like that and they're
selling um you know they can't they then
can't take that cut it up and there
where it stops correct so they're not
allowed to do that either the name on
that animal when it's killed is where it
stops right now unless it's poultry
unless it's which yes like which makes
no sense which is a lot yeah it's it's a
way more dangerous problem
okay any other
questions thank you appreciate it thank
you uh Rob Johnson from New Hampshire
Farm
Bureau thank you madam chair members of
the committee good afternoon for the
record Rob Johnson representing the New
Hampshire f is the federation's policy
director f is a Federation of New
Hampshire 10 County F
organizations uh that includes uh 20
just 2500 Family Farm members supporters
and Association of businesses we do not
support House Bill
390 um though we we do not disagree with
the sponsor's intent and probably agree
with almost everything you've heard um
that said we we do not believe that
passing state laws that conflict with
federal law as this bill does is a
solution uh I've been
before you folks I can't tell you how
many times over the last 25 years when
it comes to some pesticide laws that are
proposed I think of the some food
Freedom bills there was Senator in's
bill from last year Senate B 494 in his
committee that we have opposed for that
reason um if pass we're putting our
farmers in a position of USDA
enforcement um think of insurance and
product liability where they think
they're covered and their insurance is
wait a second you there's a yeah the
state law state allows you to do that
but the federal government doesn't that
there's uh it's confusing it's been
mentioned that there are uh uh raw milk
and
poultry yes there are exemptions but
there are exemptions under federal law
that are Ena currently enabled in in in
replacing the bill we' like to see the
committee moved forward with a
resolution uh urging the our United
States Congress to pass legislation and
or the US Department of Agriculture to
to adopt regulations supporting
flexibility in Meet inspection
regulations particularly we're talking
about Beef Pork and lamb that were sold
directly from the farm producer to the
consumer and thank you for your time and
attention I know you've got a number of
folks that like to speak with you thank
you okay any questions from the
committee representative Bixby I believe
that the last uh term at the federal
level there was a law that was trying to
get at this and do you know if the
similar law has been U the prime act
yeah the prime act yeah it didn't it did
not go anywhere but and and and no one's
trying it again this term no uh I
haven't seen anything yet I wouldn't be
surprised if they did and I I know our
our our president Joyce Brady is going
to be here and she's going to touch on
on that a little bit I think okay thank
you okay any other questions
representative gerana thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question I
was just curious because of the the very
helpful testimony the last individual
test could you tell us something about
the history I didn't know about poultry
not having to conform to these kind of
same uh same inspection guidelines so
could could you give us a little bit of
the history of why that distinction
exists in law well I think you go back
to the the Meat Inspection statues the
federal inspection statues and they came
on the books in the late 60s I think it
what I've read and heard it was a matter
of where there are a heck of a lot of
small poultry producers around that
wanted the ability to sell direct and
were able to fend off basically the the
the federal law is kind of what I've and
that's up to 20,000 birds that you so
there's there's a there's one exemption
up to a thousand then it's another up to
20 that that enables all right thank you
yeah and I think that's something what
many of us would like to see with some
legislation you know that Federal level
would you believe that the a number of
those uh producers that were raising
roughly 20,000 birds were in fact
members of the US Congress
that that would not be surprising either
yes any other questions representative
Scully please join us at the in your
seat thank you for your testimony today
Mr Johnson and I call Ma Amy
Matarazzo from
Barnstead thank you for coming to see us
this afternoon
yep please tell us where you're from and
your name Barnstead New Hampshire Amy
mozzo thank you very much good afternoon
my name is Amy mozzo my husband Brian
and I own and operate Lauren Joyce Farm
in Barnstead on our farm we sell beef
raw milk products and eggs we have been
selling beef direct to Consumer for 10
years I'm the primary operator of our
farm and my husband works as a forestry
mechanic for a large Logging Company as
a homeschooling mom and a full-time
farmer I took the time today to come
speak to the committee because I want
you to understand how large of an issue
this is for New Hampshire farmers and
for food security this bill could be
crucial for small farms to continue
farming because there are so few usca
butchers in New Hampshire on our farm we
have sold beef by the cut and wholesale
we started selling beef at local farmers
markets Farm stands such as the one in
hooks it that you were talking about and
now only from our farm we have used two
USDA inspected butchers and four custom
butchers in the last 10 years many of
our customers now struggle to afford to
buy meat buy the cut with the economy
they're barely getting by it's very hard
for a family to afford a $5,000 cow even
once a year we need to be the sell cuts
that have been processed at a non USDA
shop with the right
protocols we have had both great and
very bad experiences using both USDA and
custom shops most important reason why
we're here today whether you oppose or
support the bill is to recognize that
human health and meat safety needs to be
our number one priority I'm dedicated to
raising and selling the highest quality
meat I possibly can and do never do not
ever want to make someone sick last
summer we were using the USDA facility
that representative comto spoke about
what we experienced was unlike anything
I've ever seen my heart's desire is not
to go against the government or
authority but I can't get behind corrupt
government allowing what happened at
this facility and it was
wrong we were one of the Farms who had
to lose sleep daily concerned that our
meat was going to make make someone sick
over the years I have always thought
that using a USDA facility was truly the
only way to ensure that my meat was safe
and properly handled but sadly I do not
feel that way anymore and I'm very angry
with the USDA during the summer the
weight times on our beef kept coming
back longer and longer the individual
managing the facility continued to tell
me that they dry AED their beef so mine
would be fine they never once asked me
if I was okay with my beef being
dry-aged hanging 3 to 4 weeks the answer
would have been no there was not enough
space to dry age the beef and the
animals and the volume of animals that
were being pushed
through I'm sorry your time's up okay
would you just
conclude um I just wanted to talk about
how I've had a negative experience at a
custom shop too but overall a lot can go
wrong at both USDA and C some facilities
so we need proper guidelines and
amendments to make this bill safe so
that um New Hampshire meat will be safe
no matter who consumes it okay thank you
any questions from the committee
representative
Penza thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um can you
can you explain what happened
um they basically I'm not familiar with
this of course this is your business not
mine you said that the USDA facility was
like hanging the meat for how
long so the facility was not properly
managed and they were overbooking
themselves and they were over capacity
and they were also dry aging their own
beef in the facility which had mold on
it and so the carcasses like mine were
being hung too long and they had
excessive mold growth on them and in
order for that product to be packaged
they were hacking all of the 6 in of
mold off the beef and then packaging
what was left oh my goodness followup
followup okay so let's say if what you
brought them was worth like after they
were doing what they were going to do
and if it was done right and on time
$11,000 what did that just take off of
your
$1,000 do you know what I'm saying yes
thank you for the question um $1,000
isn't really so look at an animal it's
probably worth
$5,000 to the consumer if you buy it by
the whole um it depends on what the
yields are my yields average around 62%
on a beef and some of the ones that were
having a lot of mold cut off were
yielding in the 40s so they're
essentially you know stealing from
Farmers and you didn't get any money
back from that all their problems that
they caused you lost all of that there's
no recouping of anything from from their
mistakes correct yep and in the 10 years
that I've sold beef um whenever there's
an issue it's always my problem and my
family like I was going to talk about
the custom issue we had a gentleman that
we were doing business with he damaged
hundreds of pounds of our hamburger and
we because it was a custom situation too
um we we had to eat it
so selling meat as a farmer is not all
you know happy
roses okay any other questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
and telling us that aspect of uh of this
meat processing process yes app thank
you for the opportunity do you have
written testimony that you can share
with us even if it's written hand okay
that's a
fine okay thank
you uh call Gary
sandborn from
Deerfield okay please tell us your name
where you're from and
it's a Gary sandborn Willowdale Farm
Deerfield New Hampshire I'm ninth
generation on our farm um we have used
Daryl Robinson East Conway beef before
he burned while he burned we had to go
to another facility two different ones
the two we used were not USDA we had
horrible experiences we lost two cows at
one facility it was not cooled properly
same idea the mold was growing on it and
I refused to take the animals I made
them pay for the animals I never got f
paid for them I went to another facility
that was not USDA with five pigs there
when I walked in to pick up our animals
the girl was smoking a cigarette in one
hand putting bags handles of meat in
bags without gloves on and flies flying
around the
room while I'm sitting there watching
her and she makes a comment I should
probably go get my gloves but they're
too far away they're 50 feet away I says
well I hope those aren't my animals and
I walked in the next door it was still
in the Breezeway there was a tub of um
hams not covered not in plastic just
sitting there with flies flying around
them so that's the first two places I
used after Daryl burn down so we stopped
processing our animals we had 150 head
at that time we were not doing anything
until Daryl opened back up Daryl's here
today me Conway so those two incidences
were horrible we are licensed to sell by
the pound off our farm individual Cuts
holes Hales quarters we were selling to
restaurants a bed and breakfast and
several stores before Co we were selling
high-end stores in Manchester good
high-end restaurants and I would not use
a non USDA facility whatsoever for no
reason I know two or three people that
do it in their backyard the sanitation
is even not even close to what USDA is
there's been some very outlandish facts
here thrown around about USDA and what
they've lost and what what they have
gone as far as against them which is not
correct whatsoever from what we've seen
we've seen firsthand different
facilities USDA has been on top every
single time yes there is always a 1%
margin or small margin where something's
going to go wrong it's inevitable but
you can't take the health away of people
their safety by taking away
USDA um as far as what she was talking
about with the mold was cut off that's
not on the facility 100% they have a
USDA inspector there every single day
why did he not catch this he was not
doing his job darl will testify today
they have to take temperatures of the
meat twice a day and record it if you're
taking a temperature of a cow hanging up
and this mold off it you pushed to that
mold something ain't right and that
inspector is at fault also the farm but
also the safety in place has to be there
now if the safety is not there for USDA
what's the backyard guy going to do when
he's cutting Corners he's got too many
cows coming in too many pigs coming too
many sheep and they're in a hurry to get
these out the door are their sanitation
going to be anywhere near proper I don't
believe so but I've seen it not even
close um we use USDA in our marketing
it's a thing to brag about yes our meet
is USDA that's one thing we can brag
about it's done at a great facility
we're there every two weeks around
around the year every two weeks we're
there I walk in drop off animals
processing pick up animals and it's very
clean and neat okay thank you so your
time's up I appreciate your
testimony and uh representative wheeler
would you take your seat please thank
you mad sure uh representative
Penza um thank you madam here thank you
so much for your testimony um you tried
to get it all out fast and I was your
hover I'm sorry no no no it was really
good um cuz I think we need I mean this
all is kind of
um you know really um sad and yeah it's
um it's a lot of information for a lot
of us that we haven't heard before so
you said to me that you didn't accept
like those I think those two cows right
corre so did you get reimbursed for that
most of it to the point where I was
comfortable enough
so so if it's a USDA facility are they
taking accountability if they screw up
absolutely absolutely but a private
place will not this one did not I'm not
saying all of them like I said there is
percentage where there's going to be a
problem no matter what it is in this
world this facility did not take care of
it the correct way and we're out money
but there again I'd rather be out the
money then bring those animals into our
place and resell them out of our free
either Buy the Pound or buy the half and
hold and get somebody sick I'd take the
hit before I get somebody else sick
followup
sure so USDA facilities were following
federal laws we're doing everything the
right way everything's supposed to be
you know clean all of that and safe so
you know you're this is your business
this is your livelihood on it so I don't
understand how if we're doing everything
that we're that you're doing everything
you're supposed to do that if the other
person screws up that's supposed to be
following all these federal laws and
everything like that that you wouldn't
get reimbursed whole for that shouldn't
there be some sort of insurance or
something absolutely and if you have
deep enough Pockets you sue the Butcher
and get it back now followup for that
was talking about there was a lawsuit
brought against that
company it
disappeared and that's
fact disappear no the lawsuit
disappeared they were paid to take it
back so if you if you you
experienced two different custom shops
that were substandard in your
eyes are they still in business yes
ma'am do they still do robust business
call State I did call a state uhhuh and
I left it up to them I mean nothing I'm
can do after that I actually had the
gentleman give me the information from
the company that fcked his cooler his
cooler went down for a couple days it
was low I was cooling too too low too
hot a temperature so I called the the
company the free of dire company that
fixed his cooler and that gentleman said
do not take those animals back they were
at 48 degrees for a day and a half and
you still wanted to sell them to me and
that's when I refused
them so clearly I mean they're in in
many different areas just even from a
state inspection or you know if you
called somebody from the state and
complained about it did people are not
doing their jobs then to ensure that
even those those complaints are
addressed ma' yeah so that's kind of a
problem for everybody for anybody um
anybody other have any
questions oh one more representative
Penza um thank you madam chair thank you
for this I I would love um I would love
for you to email our committee the
information that you just stated and
those um I elaborate some more yeah that
that would be fantastic especially those
um those places that are still in
operation and we would be happy to give
that information over to the
commissioner who's not here right now
cuz this is where this stuff shouldn't
be happening at all and we need to make
sure that our farmers are you know that
we're they already up against a lot and
if you know we want um we want this to
be a a productive and uh and Lively um
that's the first two places we used I
stopped after that I didn't want to go
any further because Daryl does an
excellent job so we put our farm on hold
for a year year and a half to two years
till they get back up and running again
wow okay any other questions thank you
sir thank you um calling John
Leslie good afternoon good afternoon
Madam chair um and commissioner uh
members of the chair State your state
your name and where you're from and
Jonathan Leslie uh from Deerfield as
well um I operate a considerably smaller
Farm than Mr Sor and Senator inis um we
started in 2020 we operate we have five
acres of pasture maybe so I'm one of the
Farms that um the commissioner was
talking about who does not push product
regularly so I just got an email today
from one of the USDA processors in state
asking for booking for
2026 for animals saying they opened up
my pigs that I'd be processing at the
time in 2026 aren't even pregnant they
don't even look at the boore right now
for those animals that'll get processed
in 2026 the Lambs that I have that'll
get processed in 2026 their moms are
pregnant right now so I don't know how
they're going to grow out I don't know
where
they um you know where their weight will
be when I want to process them I have to
guess at okay they'll be ready in let's
say February but if they're not I have
to push it which you know many of our
smaller USDA processors in state can
accommodate to an extent but not you
know push it a week or two weeks or
three weeks we have to push it you know
a couple months which then will'll
continue spending money on Hay or feed
and the animals will not get bigger at
the same rate um we've been talking
about USDA versus custom butchers I've
had excellent experiences at USDA
butchers I've used Daryl here at East
from East Conway I've used Bloods down
in groten I've also used several custom
butchers who I've had excellent
experiences with I've been lucky in that
extent where I haven't seen these same
issues um you know but we do have these
USD processors that are selling Millions
upon millions of tons of animal a year
that are having problems we had Bor Bor
head last year where 10 people died 60
were hospitalized thousands were um you
know sickened USA had issues on the
books from 2022 that were saying they
were an imminent threat to human health
and they didn't do anything so we're
paying for these USDA butchers and many
times you know they're pushing things
under the rug they're not necessarily
doing the right thing um fsis which is
the food safety inspection service has a
website where they have open recalls
there's hundreds of them um
representative ktoa mentioned a few
where there was foreign matter and all
the meat um we're lucky that all of our
processors are small here in state you
know even our USDA processors they're
small they care they're part of our
community but USDA processing at the
grocery store can come from Argentina
Australia Austria Brazil Canada Chile
China Costa Rica Croatia Denmark nambia
New Zealand Nicaragua tons of countries
they have USDA equivalent processing and
country of origin required for chicken
lamb and goat it can be labeled us meat
if it if there's a process that changes
the character meaning it's cooked cured
smoked or restructured which is a roast
cut down into staks so you could be
eating beef from nambia Namibia excuse
me that is restructured and labeled as a
US
meat from Market Basket or handford okay
can you uh wrap up yes ma'am um on that
note you know this this bill will be
great for small farms such as myself to
be able to get our animals to process
the custom butchers are mainly good um
and the risk for human sickness is
relatively low based on comparing the
sizes and what we get okay thank you any
questions from the
committee so
um what would be your response to uh
some s some as we've stated we've heard
the situation where uh some custom shops
are really substandard yes ma'am I mean
there's going to be unfortunately Bad
actors in any profession um if we're
looking at custom shops here in New
Hampshire there's there's going to be
some bad actors just like there's some
USDA Bad actors um they're small enough
that the disease tracking and the issue
tracking is going to be from my
farm to a customer my farm to a
restaurant if they have an issue they
know where they got the meat from and we
can trace it and figure out what animal
it was from and deal with that
accordingly okay thank you any questions
that represent
Penza um thank you madam chair obviously
I'm fascinated by this subject because
I'm asking all the questions
um I would assume that because there's
there's a vast amount of testimony
coming from both sides here right so um
saying that they've had you know um more
problems with custom versus USDA and
stuff like that but doesn't it matter
kind of like where you are in the state
because aren't there only
four there are only four well uh East
conways stood up standing up they'll be
there'll be four soon there's three
currently
there's it's fairly spread out
throughout the state to be to be honest
it's not that tight it's not all
Southern New Hampshire area
so for example where where where are you
going to versus where the previous
testimony was I want to understand
geographically so ideally I would go to
the same processor as him East Conway in
East Conway New Hampshire North a North
ail okay um the other the other shop
I've used is in Massachusetts it's in
Groton so it's an hour and some change
okay thank you any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony this
afternoon thank you I have a card here
I'm sorry I can't read the name uh
person is from
Conway all right oh what okay when you
get it looks like it begins with a d
okay all right please state your name
and where you're
from Daryl
Daryl Robinson yep from East Conway beef
okay you we are a federal Meat
Plant
and I'm not opposing this bill but I'm
not going for it um there's a lot of
reasons for this I've been doing this
for 40 years I've seen the good I've
seen the bad I've seen the ugly on this
whole
part yes USDA
does it brings a lot of business in what
what happened that this lady was telling
us about never should have happened
these when you have an inspector there
your inspect is there to watch the
things that you're supposed to do and
temperature is the big thing in in meat
um the other things I understand these
people want to do stuff at their at
their place but
there's when you when you kill an animal
there's a lot of things inside the
animal that the government looks for
it's something they're going to have to
be trained to see because this is
something that can make you really
sick um and the mold part of it I mean
the the state's going to have to monitor
these people as far as their coolers
their temperatures cuz that's where mold
come from and when mold is on an animal
and you're you're scraping it off it's
like a it's like a fern that's gone by
and it floats in the air well it goes
all everywhere and those are things that
temperature does
create
um like I say I've done I've done all
this stuff I'd like to answer any of the
questions these people were up here
before but I couldn't but if you guys
get any questions I'd be more than happy
to to answer them okay represent Bixby
Yeah you mentioned that uh when you
Slaughter the animal and you open it up
uh there are things that the inspector
looks at and that that could poent
potentially make you sick would that be
things like the animal has some uh
characteristics of being diseased that
you didn't see when it was walking in
but in fact you when you open it up and
you see the organs you see that it's
diseased yes exactly they check in the
stomachs and the glands that's where you
find a lot of it like in the neck
um it's not it's not common but it
happens I mean we've had to throw pigs
away that's had things wrong with them
and and beef too and that's the that's
the whole thing that I worry about when
people do it at their house that they
may not see it you know that's that's
the big problem follow up so um one I it
would it would seem like since it's not
that common it would seem like uh having
someone who has seen an awful lot of
animals would be able to that person
would be able to recognize it more
readily than someone who doesn't
Slaughter that many
animals that's true in a way but in like
in when we work we take that stuff and S
give it to the inspector he goes through
it if he finds something wrong with it
he has to get a vet there to check it
and he'll say if it's good or it's bad
now I'm not saying these people can't do
that I'm not saying this at all but if
they do see something
wrong I think going to get a vet to take
a look at it because the whole purpose
of this whole thing is to make sure
people are safe eating the product
because we have a bigger problem this in
New
Hampshire a lot bigger problem than what
we're talking about right now that you
guys don't even hear about but I see and
it's not just in New Hampshire it's in
Maine it's it's everywhere now but I'd
love to have time to talk about it but I
think we're just going to keep with this
here and well what problem are you
referring to the problem
is as you're saying you want to help the
farmer in in New Hampshire okay I want
to help the farmer in New Hampshire you
have farmers in New
Hampshire that buy the same beef it's
not from their house they're selling it
at farmers markets saying it's their
beef and it's Box Beef that comes from I
TAA comes from Mexico there their
processors cut this meat for them and
has their Farm name on it when you go to
their place and you think you're buying
their beef you may be at some of them
but there's some of them out there
you're not buying the beef you're buying
beef from me this is and I've thought
this with the federal
government I I do all the
time uh representative wheeler and then
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair you're 100% right about that I've
had Farmers tell me about that before
and I'm just thinking to myself that's
crazy but I'm not I'm not a farmer I've
only ever processed a duck at a friend's
house who's a homesteader but you had
mentioned when you cut an animal open
that uh mold spores will release from
the animal I mean could you tell us more
about that is that what you meant to say
m spores will release from the animal if
that no in the case of the lady that had
the beef at a place where they kept it
for 30 days and the mold grow no you
don't get mold when you kill them and
open them up you get mold when when
there's a temperature change I see when
you get a temperature change with all
this stuff that's when mold will start
once it's already opened once it's
already opened and put in the cooler
yeah yeah temperature is the main thing
thank you representative H Haskins thank
you madam
chair did I hear that has to have an
inspector on site every time there's a
Slaughter
yes so cuz he's the one that checks so
you have to schedule the slaughtering so
that the inspector can be there we have
it we have an inspector every day every
day yep Monday through Friday that's
interesting every slaughter house has to
have a no no and the custom plants
there's a lot of good custom plants out
there but the state of New Hampshire and
the federal
government I mean the state of New
Hampshire used to send blood test out
when I first started CU I've been doing
the 38 years blood test you would you'd
have to take a blood test send it into
New Hampshire they'd send it in and have
it tested well I haven't seen that
anymore and they used to have a person
come around once a year just to make
sure everything and the government come
once a it's not enough no once a year is
not enough and and there's there's
places that can get by with all that
because they do a good job and there are
a lot of custom places but
there the ones that aren't so good that
makes the good ones look bad okay so you
have a
USDA you have a USDA Slaughter place yes
okay yeah followup yeah followup did you
have a fire did i y we just opened up
but well we just got a federal
inspection last week did you lose
animals oh
yeah yeah and I had to pay for all them
animals that we lost wow I'm sorry to
hear that that's why all them people
that had the problem with the mold and
all this stuff that didn't get
reimbursed with
that they should get reimbursed for that
because that wasn't their choice on this
and this should be a followup on the
state of New Hampshire
because this looks like a cover up to me
it either looks like a cover up from the
USDA or the state of New
Hampshire uh oh represent
Penza thank you madam chair thank you so
much for your testimony holy okay so I
just I wantan to I want to backtrack
quickly so you're saying that um that
some of these some of the some of the
farmers or facilities
are going to the farmers market where
I've purchased uh steak or pork or
something like that and they're saying
it's theirs and it's
help me understand that and it's not
because
whoever they're getting where are they
getting it from then it's they call it
Box Beef haned shop and I mean Shaws all
they sell Box Beef in every every store
because it comes in you buy cases of
ribe eyes that's all you get ribe eyes
you get cases of t-bones and pous that's
all there is they cut them up they come
from Canada they come from Mexico they
come from Argentina well it got to the
point and this is why I'm fighting for
the small farmer here why I'm bringing
this up because if they go to the farmis
market with one beef say 12 riye staks
and the guy next door's got 500 but he's
got less beef than they
got he's buying this box beef through
his Federal plant and putting their
label on it and and I've fought this
with the government and I I did just
last week and there's nothing they can
do about but that should be under the
state that that you're in your state
they're in your state doing this and
these are people that are they're good
people
but it's lying yeah represent follow up
um my other question is about how you
said um and maybe you can give it like a
time frame when did you feel is if the
um the safety precautions or controls
that were in place have started to
decline you talked about um you talked
about a blood test you talked about um
you know once a year is not enough when
was it more and then like it started to
decline can you give it like over a
period of time it was probably
the well
been preco 20 oh wait before that oh way
way before that yeah you're talking 25
years ago was probably the last time
that I'd seen a blood test through the
state of New
Hampshire I I don't know where I don't I
don't know what happened I really I have
no idea representative
King thank you madam chair um and thank
you for taking so many questions I've
got a question that's kind of from out
left field here um
I'm thinking that in a lot of ways our
whole system is is they they call it
just in time you know food gets to the
grocery stores just in time and and it
seems like if we only have like three
USDA butchers and stuff I'm concerned
that there may come a day where like
something really bad happens and all of
a sudden uh meat just can't get to the
grocery stores or get to people's tables
anymore
because you know uh all of a sudden
there's no gasoline in the gas stations
or the grid has gone down or something
bad has happened and now people are
starving and one thing I kind of like
about these things is it decentralizes
this highly centralized system and you
know I don't know I'm just I have this
fantasy in my head that like people can
go to like their local guy next door and
get some fresh you know meat that's like
never been frozen never been
refrigerated it was slaughtered that day
and take it home and it seemed like
that's something you just can't do
anymore but it used to be done back in
the good old days and I don't know I
just I like the idea that someday we
could do that again where things are
just like this um ecotopia idea you know
and and it just seems like right now
there's like you've got to truck your
meat all over creation and you've got to
pass it through centralized Bure
bureaucratized hands and I just want
like my neighbors's good you know beef
right next door and I don't don't want
fossil fuels to have to be transporting
it or touching it or refrigerating or
freezing it or and I don't want to have
to pay some inspector $365 a day to
stand there you know I just want to cut
all that out and like I don't know I
just is that are those days gone can
they come
back well you don't have to you don't
have to pay an inspector anyway that's
not true if he works overtime you have
to pay him you get 40 hours free a week
um
do I think it's gone yeah I do
but the stuff you buy in the
stores doesn't have to be frozen for 12
weeks because they put gas in the
bags and that keeps supposedly keeps the
meat so you don't have to freeze it
which I I am totally against 12 weeks
not being frozen and I would say
maybe four or five days if we cut a beef
and vacuum packet I wouldn't want to
push it any longer than that there's a
gas you if you look it up they put a gas
in the bag and I've always said this is
the reason when I was a kid they didn't
have Box Beef they had swinging beef
they call it where they used to come
right into the thing and you'd cut it
and do this now it's not like that and
I've and I've felt that's right along I
have no scientific proof this is why we
have problems with our children nowadays
with with the Down syndrome and all
these little things that kids never had
and it has to come from
somewhere and I've always said the meat
I really think that's where it's coming
from is the gas and the bags was when
you go 12 weeks without freezing it
there's a problem
here any other questions Representatives
goly thank you madam chair thank you for
coming this is
Illuminating um does the federal
government require you to have liability
Insurance oh yeah I wouldn't dare not to
yeah I mean no they don't require it no
oh they don't right but you do as
somebody yeah okay thank yeah yeah any
other
questions thank you so very much for for
coming and educating us on a lot of
different things here you didn't want to
hear yeah Lucen
Brown hello hi please tell us your name
where are you from my name is Lucen
Brown I and please speak close to the
mik hi I'm Lucen Brown I'm from New
Hampton New Hampshire my husband and I
are first generation farmers in New
Hampton we raise sheep beef and poultry
on our farm and sell Meats directly to
our
consumers as of now we sell retail cuts
from our farm stand the beef and lamb
has to be USD inspected to be sold by
individual cuts to our consumers however
the chickens and turkeys we raise are
butchered and processed on our Farm or
at a custom meat shop that is not USDA
inspected or
approved if House Bill 396 were to
become a law it would greatly benefit
New Hampshire's farmers and consumers as
of now there are only two USDA inspected
slaughter houses in New Hampshire that
process lamb and goats I have to
schedule butcher dates for an unknown
amount of animals before the animals are
even conceived because the weight lists
are so
long House Bill 396 has the opportunity
to increase commerce between farmers
skilled custom Meat Shops and consumers
it would allow restaurants to support
our state's Farm businesses without
having to import Meats from other states
or countries food safety is extremely
important to me as both a consumer and a
producer is critical for butchers and
meat processors to maintain a high level
of Sanitation and food safety regardless
of if the meat has a USDA label on it or
not I would love for us to find a way to
get safe locally grown and processed me
into the hands of more consumers even if
farmers were allowed to legally sell
retail cuts from USDA approved
facilities which are different than
inspected in the state it would greatly
benefit the farmers and maintain food
safety standards set by the USDA thank
you thank you and do you have uh your
written testimony that you can share
with the clerk yep okay thank you any
questions for
Lucien no thank you very much for taking
the time and waiting and being patient
and uh and and giving us your your
testimony we appreciate it I call Joyce
Brady from New Hampshire Farm Bureau
Joyce Brady Columbia New Hampshire um I
have to first start by revising I said
good afternoon I think I have to say
good evening now sorry no that's fine my
name is Joyce Brady I'm the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau president along
with a diversified livestock farmer in
Coos County part of my farm includes a
New Hampshire licensed processing
facility in which I can process USDA
slaughtered animals and sell as
individual cuts to the end user I have a
license under the department Health and
Human
Service I am very excited about today
this discussion I've been talking about
this for years that we need to do
something
but first I'd like to thank this
committee for allowing me to testify
today I'd also like to thank the
sponsors of this bill for tackling the
subject that need we need changes and
not just for our Farmers for but for our
consumers as
well as much as I'd like to see New
Hampshire law that allows more freedom
within the meat industry we need to
remember that the USDA has the final say
with that said just last month I was the
New Hampshire delegate at the American
Farm Bureau federation's annual
convention during the delegate session
we passed three different policies
dealing with this subject one policy was
very much like this bill a USDA EX
extion from meat processed and sold
within the state to the end user the
second policy was about allowing a third
party inspector on the kill floor while
the third policy was directing the
American Farm Bureau Federation board of
directors to set up a committee that
will start working on issues that hinder
the small processing facilities across
the country and this is not just in New
Hampshire this is not just a New England
I've heard the Farm Bureau presidents
from all across the country this is a
problem across the country
I also just recently worked with the New
Hampshire Food Alliance to help them
Write a brief for the meat and poultry
section of the New Hampshire food and
agriculture strategic plan this brief
also mentions exploring the feasibility
of a USDA approved hybrid program with a
new
Administration with them talking about
the importance of the farmer with the
make America healthy again movement and
afbf new policies I believe that this
committee should change this bill into a
resol solution for the USDA and the US
Congress this is the time for us to move
forward and make something happen but
please don't put the farmer and the
processor at risk of violation with the
USDA I think the USDA is ready I think
covid changed things you now have some
states with a state inspection they're
allowed to cross state lines because of
a program since Co Now's the Time but
let's do it right
right I'm going to stop
there okay thank you questions from Miss
Brady uh representative wheeler you had
your hand and then representative
Bixby thank you very much for coming and
testifying before the
committee could you just tell us would a
resolution be would a resolution
genuinely be better than just moving to
itl this bill or doing something other
than that I mean yes so I feel that a
resolution to the USDA in the Congress
would be forceful along with all these
other things with afbf coming in at them
with you guys coming at them I think we
could change some minds and get some
real reform to help everyone across the
country it's not just us um and then you
don't have um Farmers or custom
processors having the feds show up and
paying
fines thank you represent Bixby yes so
um Senator inis mentioned a um a sort of
roving inspector program
where uh a custom shop can have a u an
inspector intermediately uh in in no not
not intermediately like once in a while
um intermittently intermittently yes um
it's been a long day yeah so um we only
have two more cards is that something
you've ever uh availed yourself of or or
would consider so you have to be USDA
inspected for that USDA inspector okay
okay so the so you said said okay so
you're you you are you USDA inspected
for processing but not for Slaughter no
I am not I am State of New Hampshire
inspected my processing facility is
inspected under the Department of Health
and Human Services so I have to take my
animal to a USDA Slaughter or the state
the one I use is actually a state
inspected but they've got the USDA
approval to cross state lines I bring
the carcass back to my place hang it and
and then cut it up and I can sell it to
individual Cuts because I've been Pro
the the kill has been done under USDA
and then my processing facility has been
inspected okay thank you so what I need
I need to be able to kill on my
floor yes at some point in time without
the USDA right okay thank you so I
thought the state didn't have an
inspection program I am I am a state
approved processing facility under
Department of Health and Human
Services I'm a processing facility okay
thank you do a slight clarification uh
so uh when um Mr clero was here last
year uh he explained that there are
exemptions Avail a number of exemptions
available for the processing end of
things and this is one of them uh what
there where where there aren't
exemptions at this point are in the
slaughter are at the slaughter end
gotcha okay thank you representative
Gruber and then Penza thank you madam
chair uh thank you for coming um you you
mentioned uh you think a resolution to
USDA and Congress could help move in One
Direction could you just share two or
three the key things that should be in
that resolution that really resonate
with
you with me personally well with your
group and the people you're working with
what the key things you think should be
so one of the things is allowing a third
party inspector on the kill floor um
back oh boy about 18 20 years ago Dr
Crawford tried to put together a plan
for the USDA to approve and they would
not approve a third party inspector they
said it had to be either a state
employee or a federal employee if we
could get a a a third party inspector
such as a vet a vet tech someone that's
gone through some type of program um
that would help alleviate the whole
inspector problem any that that would be
a game changer for me uh any other
issues just one any other key issues you
want that resolution to include
um I think Rob Johnson has written
something up
um
so I
think there's been a lot said here
today um but I know that he he has got
some writing and we can get that to you
thank you thank you represent Penza and
then representative Bixby is that
okay um thank you thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question so you
would have to just so I understand you
have to bring the animals someplace to
get slaughtered and then you bring it
back and that okay
um do you believe that there is
[Music]
um enough um skilled people or there
that there could be to um whether they
are private it doesn't you know USDA not
USDA State trained employee whatever
ever it may be but if these people are
all um have been trained certified um
capable that we would be able to do
something without all of the level of
bureaucracy if I mean could we be able
to run uh efficient operations like this
and um and have have multitudes of
people that are that are trained and
efficient is there a is you know is
there enough of a population you know we
always have a lack of let's say the HVAC
industry or we have a lack of this is
there would we would we have if we open
that up like if it just happened where
would we be at with amount of people
that would actually know what to do to
be able to make this happen for New
Hampshire where would the uptick be the
uptick would be in the small the very
small person so right in my area up in
Coos County I can think of four custom
places and they're all mostly a one meat
cutter maybe two but if that gave the
farmer the ability to sell individual
Cuts you've opened up a whole new market
Without Really adding any skill to the
industry it's about opening up the
markets follow up but wouldn't those
folks that let's say those four Customs
they would have to still go through
something some sort of certification
train
and that they would have just like
anybody else like they would have to
probably maybe every single make sure
that you know um that their training
their knowledge if there's anything
that's up to date or whatever that they
would you know keep their licensing or
whatever or seal of approval from state
or federal government so do you think
that um those four custom P people for
example would jump at the chance to do
that to be able to open up um that for
all different small places and shops in
New Hampshire I think so I think if it's
not too much of a burden um financial
and time consuming burden I think we all
want the best for the end end user the
the customer we all want them eating
locally because if they're eating
locally that means they're buying from
our Farmers that we're processing their
animals
for okay represent Biby oh I'm sorry but
as far as if we were to open up a big
facility another USDA facility that
takes a lot of people do I I think it's
about helping the small the small person
thank you okay so um would you or Rob
Johnson be able to uh provide us with
some suggested text for a resolution
because I don't think we I don't think
we want to try to like word Smith it
right now no no and he's he has got some
stuff okay already to give to you okay
great but I guess what I for personally
right now my only hindrance is the kill
floor because I've got
we have another Avenue of processing
it's through the DHHS so our big
hindrance is the is the kill floor right
thank you thank you okay appreciate your
time this
afternoon I call Kyle
forite uh good afternoon Madam chair
committee members my name is Kyle fory I
own and operate a farm in Guilford New
Hampshire with my wife Amy uh we mainly
raise a grassfed beef and lamb pastured
pork turkey and chicken uh we're very
familiar with using uh processing
facilities in the state and have for
several
years uh a lot of the things that I was
going to mention today have already been
mentioned and I don't want to like
reiterate it facing a lot of the similar
issues of having to make dates too far
in advance um you know just the
turnaround time tends to be stretched
out as a smaller Farm it's harder for us
to have like consistent processing dates
throughout the year it's also relative
to we're in the Northeast and a lot of
it's seasonal you know it's like if I
raise a lamb it doesn't make sense for
me to keep it all winter it's not going
to get much bigger you know and so even
though it would be easier for me to get
a processing date in the spring that
doesn't mean that that makes sense for
us in the bottom line and so I I think
part of what this bill is trying to
accomplish is giving the opportunity to
open up the market to these smaller
facilities and I think a key Point
really just after hearing everybody
speak is
that I think people come to to a farmer
like me because they know me and they
trust me and I think that's the whole
concept behind it it's about getting
the bureaucracy out of it and giving
people the opportunity to make the
choice themselves
as opposed to feeling like we have to
have this whole huge system in order to
protect them because they don't know
what they're doing I think people have
gravitated away from that and why it's
why they've there's been a huge uptick
especially after Co and the supply chain
issues I mean it was unbelievable the
change that happened and that hasn't
gone away um and I think it's only going
to get bigger and I think the problem is
there's just no room to
grow um um it's very difficult within
the current
system to think about
expanding and for me personally I think
I would love the ability to be able to
bring processing onto the farm you're
eliminating the trucking of the animals
which is significant it's also there's
all kinds of added losses to that like
the animals physically lose weight
during traveling it's pretty stressful
on them and you know I mean it's like we
raise these animals and they're almost
like pets you know it's like you have a
personal relationship with them and
that's what people appreciate is that
there's this Dynamic of knowing where
your food comes from and then so there's
a bit of a disconnect with the current
system and the way that we then do the
processing they're going to some far
away land you know they don't understand
what's going on and I've been on farms
before where we've processed animals
just for own personal consumption and
it's a totally different experience for
the animal itself
than going through the whole process uh
that we have to do
now and so I don't know that the way
that this bill is written is fully how
it should be I see a lot of the
arguments being made and they're good
ones but I do think that there's no
doubt that there's a huge issue here
okay can you conclude please um yeah I
think mainly I'm definitely into the
idea of trying to get involved uh with
our state to help get the prime act
approved on the federal level um they've
been trying to put it through for eight
years every year they put it in it never
gets out of committee so um maybe we
need to send some uh lobbies or
something I don't know okay yeah I'm
good thank you thank you any questions
representative
King thank you madam chair uh thank you
for your
testimony you're talking about how it
would be nice if Farmers could process
the meat on their own farm and sell it
um and that sounds cool but historically
I could be wrong here but historically
it seems like uh back in the day Farmers
would take their pig or their cow I mean
they wouldn't even put them in a truck
they would literally walk it to the
local butcher and the butcher would
Slaughter it and I think the butcher
would sell the meat too the farmer
wasn't really interested in getting the
meat back and then taking it home and
then trying to be the salesperson to me
it seems a little bit like
the idea of the farmer also being the
salesperson for the meat is sort of like
a it's like a response to something
that's blocking that original process
that historical process from happening
what is blocking that historical process
from happening where people could just
literally walk their their their meat to
the butcher the butcher would butcher it
and then sell it locally why why doesn't
that happen
anymore well I think you know I mean our
entire Market Market structure is
completely different and everybody's
used to going to the grocery store uh
there's a huge convenience element to it
uh one of the things that we've started
doing is an online Farm Store where
people can order online and then get it
delivered to their house and that's
helped a lot um I think it's just people
are used to you know they're not going
to a butcher shop and to the produce
shop and it's all in one spot and so
we're competing against that um I think
also it's just the distance you know
there just isn't enough facilities and I
think that's part of what this bill is
trying to address because the custom
shops are everywhere like there's dozens
of them I have one right up the street
for me and you know some of them may be
good and may be bad I personally have
not been using them because I only sell
retail and we have to use the
USDA um and so if but I have had
conversations with some of the local
custom shops who are eager and waiting
for business from someone like me I
think it's it's just a matter of you
know we can't do it because we're
selling retail cuts and that's the way
our business model is um and I you know
having talked with some of these uh
processors I personally don't feel a lot
of concern about
safety uh interacting with them directly
you know these facilities are not just
like somebody's backyard they're you
know inspected facilities they just
don't have an inspector on site
inspecting each animal it's really
really the main
difference representative
Penza um thank you madam chair thank you
representative uh King for that CU I was
thinking about that too like it this the
process is so different than what it
used to be I mean I remember growing up
and you'd go to the local butcher but so
do you think that it would ever go back
to that or is it just because there's
not enough I mean here in conquered
there's a local butcher but he's
obviously not um Outback yeah you know
slaughtering so it's just it's very
different I think a lot of them do uh
like most of the USDA facilities have a
retail shop as well um okay I just think
it's more about convenience people are
used to going to the grocery store you
get everything you need why are they
going to go to a second place you know
and they might have you know they might
appreciate the quality better and it
would be worth it to do it sometimes but
maybe not for the everyday meal you know
thank you okay I have one last uh one
last card thank you so much for your
coming out today and speaking with us
and if you have written testimony uh
please share it with a clerk
here uh last but not least we have
representative Erica Leon uh I don't
know if anybody else wishes to speak at
all but this is the last pink card I
have good afternoon good afternoon thank
you madam chair I won't try and keep us
to me being here eight hours straight
because I'm sure you've been here just
about as long uh my for the record my
name is Erica Leon I represent Dairy
which is Rockingham 13 and I am a
co-sponsor of this bill um I have been
lucky enough to be able to buy a half
beef even from land that touches mine uh
but not everybody has enough freezer
space or is able to deal with the cost
of getting half a beef um we recently
purchased it and we only had a 40% yield
coming back from a USDA facility with
holes in the packaging so I got meat
that had been slaughtered only a few
days earlier and Frozen that has massive
ice crystals within the ground beef this
was an issue of the processing so I I I
like my local farmer they're literally a
neighbor I can walk across the street
and go from my land to their land so I
didn't ask them to eat that cost of
having only a 40% yield off the hanging
weight um instead of the higher 60% that
you would expect and I didn't hold them
accountable for the fact that there were
holes in the packaging but it makes it a
lot harder for me to go ahead and keep
supporting my local
farms I would like to see more of an
opportunity for everybody to be able to
get happy meat grown locally by good
Farmers where you can look in them in
the eye shake their hand and have a
conversation about where the meat is
processed and how it's processed because
because right now when it goes into the
big USDA machine there's a lot of
unanswered questions and it just doesn't
give us the level of safety that we all
used to think the government stamp
provided so I really would like to see
whatever we can do in order to increase
the ability for Neighbors to transact
with neighbors to eat happy beef and
happy pigs um and be able to have good
food raised locally and just really
support one another um I do think that
if you look towards a res solution I I
think that this might be something that
has enough interest that if you come
together with the language we may even
be able to suspend the rules in order to
do a late Drafting and late introduction
of a house resolution if we have
language that works because I think that
good food raised well slaughtered well
and at prices that allow Farmers to keep
their Farms running and allow households
to eat that meat is something that
everybody can agree on um so while I
would like to move forward and try and
see what we can do to provide whatever
carve outs we can for New Hampshire
consumers for New Hampshire farmers and
New Hampshire processors um I I also
would like to see us encouraging the
federal level um got a message into the
perennial sponsor of the Prime act so
I'll let you know if he's coming back to
do it again this year uh which would be
great to have but I would just urge you
to understand that having a government
stamp doesn't mean that all is well
sometimes it's a lot more important to
be able to look somebody in the eye
shake their hand and really talk through
the process as well well and be
comfortable in the process if we bring
more of this back inh house to New
Hampshire so we can have New Hampshire
specific meet with New Hampshire
specific inspections I think we'll have
a lot more confidence and quite frankly
I'd be in favor of having a law that you
can't advertise something as New
Hampshire beef or New Hampshire pork
unless it actually lived in New
Hampshire ate in New Hampshire grew in
New Hampshire and has now returned to
New Hampshire I I recognize with I am
wrapping it up I recognize with the
shortage of processing facilities maybe
we can't also say slaughtered and
processed in New Hampshire because
there's times when somebody needs to go
across the border I hear there's no
poultry USDA processors within the state
um but let's have our New Hampshire beef
be New Hampshire beef um so that we can
have some good truth in
advertising thank you representative
King oh representative King go ahead
thank you madam chair um thank you for
your testimony have you ever experiened
or known people who experienced um
farmers who took their their beef for
example to a USDA Butcher and then got
back meat that was mislabeled like like
cuz I've I've had experien with that
somebody we buy from where it's like
labeled like a ribey and it's like
that's a top round does do they not even
know what they're you know what I mean
do they know know what they're doing
anymore I mean have you experience that
yourself uh thank you for the question
some of my packages of meat that were
labeled and the most recent both with
the trade name and the farm name so they
had I thought that I had two different
cows coming to me because some said X
and some said y on the label and I had
packages with the same exact label that
one was one pound and an entirely
different cut than the three pound cut
that I found on another um I think that
the USD inspectors and the processors
are doing their best but they're not
perfect so we shouldn't hold New
Hampshire specific people to that a
level of perfection they can't be
achieved by the federal government
programs either
okay thank you any other
questions thank you representative Lon
we appreciate it thank you if I may get
the blue blue sheet up
there um online uh through the online
portal we had
326 people in support of this
bill and 16 in
opposition and for our sheet here we had
one two three four five six seven in
support and five in
opposition and with that I'm going to
close the
hearing on HB
396 and thank you all for your attention
we are will have a work session tomorrow
morning to discuss more on what uh we
heard for the three bills this afternoon
so have a good rest of the evening and
do I hear a motion to adjourn so moved
thank you we are adjourned yep